hey what's going on it's Bill Burr how
are you and it's time for the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
Morning podcast I'm just checking in on
you and I'm also checking in on somebody
else
somebody else who's enjoying his liquid
death product placement hydrated
hydrated uh has a new special on Amazon
yes called the last late night the one
and only
Mr Steve Byrne thank you William how are
you sir how are you Stephen how are you
nice to see you very formal Mr liquid
just wrap the film
I did
I did yes it is it is it's done done
like does the kids say you're not done
you're not real for real to the edit Bay
anyway look at my big stupid Charlie
Brown head anymore yeah anymore you know
Steve I thought I hated myself before I
did this movie but if when you've been
there but but I wasn't in it I wrote and
directed so I had to be there to oversee
every but like but I met you
in connecting flight in Dallas one time
when you were in the middle of doing
Sullivan and Son and you were sitting
there looking like Jack Lemmon in
Glengarry Glenn Ross when you didn't get
the good leads and you were just sitting
there with this 600 yard stare and I'm
going how's it going Steve and you're
like you know if I could go back to the
20 year old me oh I think yeah right now
I think I would tell him not to do this
don't get in this [ __ ] business I
work you would think that when you're
after doing this for you know me 25
28 30 years for you 31 in March 31 so 25
years for me
I work three times as hard now than I
ever did and I think about those times
in my 20s when you would just show up
and just do the show and that was it you
couldn't sleep and then and then hit on
women afterwards yeah that was it and if
you struck out you just went to a food
truck and you laughed that was it yeah
that was it it was it was and you
weren't happy with that because you
wanted more because you didn't realize
that making TV and movies was work you
thought it was fun Steve yeah that's
what it looks like right you show up
there's a bunch of show Girls and a
cowboy on the set and it's like ah this
is Hollywood this is cool I know but
once you get it done though it is worth
it once it's done you look at it like oh
this is [ __ ] good it is worth it yeah
well you're you you have a uh see this
isn't about me no but you got a guest
right we're here to promote you're
special but hold on but you you
accomplished something that that's I
think as I bought all my Twitter
followers okay I'm just finally gonna
come clean
well tell me how to do that then you go
to my Filipino website okay so you give
them a dollar rate can you give me my
record's number now America because I
know you guys once everybody gets in
that thing everybody texts each other
once you hit that tax bracket that's
when everybody's friends talk to Joe Coy
maybe you must know some things I don't
yeah
um
okay what are you what are you asking me
but my point is that I like your flare
on your shirt is it Friday
bring some of your personalities to the
podcast I do like that you're wearing a
pirate's house this has been a point of
attention here we [ __ ] go we're not
going anywhere Steve we're gonna sit
right there we're gonna hash it out like
a couple of mature men without raising
our voices
all right
for the longest time Steve from
Pittsburgh Pittsburgh Penguins fan huge
Pittsburgh Steelers fan you go to
baseball
Yankees fan hold on hold on Ice fan wow
that's weird it's almost like you're
you're on the bandwagon with the two
teams that win championships and the
Pirates you turn your back on I was with
the pens
adopted daughter you never spoke to
could you root for the pet for the
Pirates right now knowing that every
year you're getting these draft picks
and there's a fire jump on the [ __ ]
Yankees when we were look this is when I
honestly appreciated the Yankees was uh
yet another Dynasty post 911 then I I
went out to that to that game that I got
tickets to
and I was on the bus you you know what
you earned those things and I saw George
Bush throughout the pitch and I got
caught up in the Euphoria but I was like
this is [ __ ] amazing then I started I
mean I got bankrupted the country and
gave all the money to his Oil Company
boys
that guy yeah hey
I'm not sure they all end up with the
house in Martha's Vineyard except for
Jimmy Carter he's still out there that
guy's a public servant in his 90s
swinging a hammer building houses
where's everybody else something right
now they're all at Epstein Island gang
banging tying up underage chicks in blue
and red ties that's what's really
happening out there
but I I went to that game you didn't go
and then you for years kept that secret
and you got to see all the famous story
of
um
somebody approached the comedy seller
with a with a gig you did stand up on a
bus yeah there was some Atlanta Braves
fans coming up so that must have been 99
yeah it was for Wells Fargo
yeah yeah and they were coming up and
they were going to take a bus from
Manhattan to Yankee Stadium and they
wanted to have a comedian on the bus
yeah do stand up the whole way up there
now to me to this day that is an easy
[ __ ] gig all you got to do is just
[ __ ] on yourself and just and just and
just take okay so whatever anyway she
offered it to me and Jim Norton yeah and
Jim Norton was like you know Heming and
Han about it yeah and I was like I'll
[ __ ] do it you know I don't give a
[ __ ] right and then Jim bailed right and
then we were sitting at the seller table
oh Jim you [ __ ] weasel right we
started giving each other [ __ ] right
yeah I started getting a few in on him
and he goes whatever bus boy and the
whole [ __ ] table like an EF button
commercial everybody just stopped what
he goes why are you calling a busboy he
goes Bill Burr's gonna do stand up on a
bus ticket and it was like what dude
needle off the Record and I took a I
took a headlining set it was 45 minutes
there was there was people who weren't
even comedians listening laughing or
feeling bad because I just even that
actual bus boy was like and I just sat
there and took this what [ __ ] kills
me like a month later yeah Keith
Robinson came in with a Keith Robinson
shirt on that was to Keith Robinson and
we started [ __ ] on him yeah and he
stood up and he ran out of the cellar he
ran out of the out of the restaurant
and I was sitting there like I didn't
know you could do that you just get up I
thought you had to sit there and take it
so anyway took it yeah the whole time
I knew I wasn't doing it right but I
knew you were doing it but I didn't say
anything yeah I didn't say anything was
that before or after but I didn't say is
that before after Bobby showed that
horrific video of you on the roast what
year was that because that was one of
the most humiliating things ever and I
think maybe I was like Steve's taken
enough of a pounding that was probably
right around the same time all right
this is what happened Steve who innocent
Steve Young Steve doesn't know any
better just happy to be here hey just
wants to tell some jokes and you know
ease the pain of somebody's work week
right yeah you guys are going to [ __ ] on
me and call me Lego head hair and AIDS
beard every time I show up and I'm just
gonna take it and love it you guys are
great oh AIDS beard I remember that it
was all patchy it was all patchy who
came out it was a great one AIDS beer
that was a great one
um
so he borrows Bobby cam Bobby camera
Bobby Kelly's video camera to film his
audition for SNL you're like 18 months
into the [ __ ] business so whatever
like an IDI and then he gives the camera
back and Steve Byrne glutton for punish
left the tape with the camera
and Bobby edited the worst parts of it
together because you just leave it
running Bobby
those shark guys Kelly
that's when he was fighting a burger
he's the I that eyelid goes up like a
[ __ ] shark you know and the only way
you can make Bobby docile is if you turn
them upside down like a shark that's
when they're immobile oh like an
alligator you rub your belly you know
what's funny though you know what's
funny is he has been Jolly Bobby ever
since he lost the weight Annie no but no
no no no once he had the kid all right
he seems like the Grinch the light the
pilot light came back on yeah those dark
guys got a little hey there may be Brown
at this point
they're not midnight black the only guy
I ever met with black guys
I think they might be brown now and then
he got his big producer glasses yeah he
became yeah and he's like this [ __ ]
guy that everybody loves but now he's
losing the weight and they and they are
like it's like a horror movie they're
Excavating evil Bobby with every pound
that he loses
he's becoming Bleaker Street Bob again
he's a neighborhood guy what's up Keith
hey what's up guys hey when he gets to
when he starts wearing a leather jacket
again you better make sure you know
where all your video cassettes are let
me just tell you that right now
he wore well anyways that story he
edited the worst parts of it together
and a Colin Quinn's Roasters patrice's
roast who is patrice's roast Bobby like
in eighth grade you pull out the TV with
the VCR and everything and he hooked it
up and he showed the worst parts of it
and uh everybody was there but I was
emceeing that night at the cellar and
people came in they couldn't look at me
oh we were all yelling shut it off they
couldn't look at me we're all yelling
shut up because it wasn't roast jokes he
just had this videotape of you in a
private moment of [ __ ] that you were
going to edit out dude it was like the
closest thing to a snuff film
I ever want to see and I just remembered
oh my God I remember going over to this
Cellar and you were just sitting there
oh you're hosting right I say hey Steve
what's up man you didn't look at me like
I'm surprised you're still even talking
to him
that was just like
and I tried to tell Bobby I tried to go
Bobby
you [ __ ] destroyed they didn't get he
got mad because I think he kind of knew
yeah yeah
it was like you know what he was he was
like peshy when he shoots spider no
don't make me think about what I just
did I can't dig a hole I never dug a
[ __ ] hole before I'm surprised you
want to be my friend anymore more bill
that was me yeah but Bobby I remember
Bobby those are all broken
that was a uh I want to think back to
that if I was even remotely a healthy
person yeah like 90 of my friends I
would not have oh oh and then them
included because we've all grown as
people we could all go back in time like
Bobby now could not hang back hang out
with Bill back then and me now could not
hang out with Bobby back no no no just
that whole that's why I stopped uh that
like the table was just toxic there were
nights where it was like I was sitting
there and I was still like you know this
young comic and I was like you guys like
you do this to each other this is crazy
like this is not normal and so I had to
sit at the bar you couldn't eat rice
when you were down there oh dude I
I was eating Chinese food and I hear
that and I look up and Norton's taking
pictures of me with chopsticks eating
Korean food
ah we all took we all took it it was
awful and there was so many funny guys
down there and we didn't create one
[ __ ] thing
to have [ __ ] to make each other feel
horrible well that's what's funny
nowadays when you hit this [ __ ] kids
bitching about [ __ ] I'm just sitting
there going and
and what happened I was like all right I
give that a five oh brutal the the most
it was stupid I'm not by the way the
younger Comics or maybe watch this this
is not what you wanted to do it was
stupid it was just stupid it like that
is one of the dumbest periods of my
career that has been romanticized into
this Leonard Institute and it became
better because they didn't no we didn't
we became angrier and more self-loathing
and that doesn't turn into better comedy
no no no no it was it just causes you to
snap on a crowd I guess people who like
that type of [ __ ] those are such fun
days speaking of snapping on crowds was
there anything better than Nick de Paulo
going up doing a [ __ ] set oh god I've
never seen a guy in the middle of
killing yeah and one person clears their
throats and he just and it was just it
it was a it was amazing and then he
would just they would love him and then
whatever he said to that person they
would [ __ ] hate him
and the whole crowd like you just he
would just suck all the oxygen out of
the room and then he would just do his
next bit and it was so good he would be
killing again yeah I've never seen
anybody be able to do that that guy is
one of the best Comics I've ever [ __ ]
seen
uh I I wanna like he
especially at that time like I love you
trying to figure him out
with you though because I did a tour
with him and every night he would be
talking to me like this and then he
would get out on the [ __ ] stage and
he was like this and I was like what is
he doing what's going on with his
posture and I realized he was looking
unden he was getting underneath yeah the
stage lights with his brow because he
knew someone was going to have a problem
and his head was going back and forth
like a [ __ ] security camera he was
looking for the bathroom tile that's
missing on the floor there's always one
oh no there's always one it was great
some of the best sets I've ever seen
even Greer Barnes Colin man that was
just such an amazing time Geraldo rest
his soul all of those guys down there I
used to [ __ ] Geraldo to me was the
guy where I I was like what the [ __ ] I
mean just constantly generating [ __ ] and
then there were there were no cell phone
cameras and nobody knew about that club
and people were just wandering and these
[ __ ] lunatics
yeah I mean dude I always tell that
story that guy took his [ __ ] dick out
on stage man it was [ __ ] hilarious
killed killed who pulled a dick out on
stage okay maybe it was his Club maybe
it wasn't
he got into it with this chick in the
front row like it was a late night dude
yeah and he goes if you don't stop
[ __ ] uh
I forget what she said yeah
she just said she didn't think he was
funny she was a woman of a certain age
and she didn't give a [ __ ] sure she had
the Large Marge truck driver Vibe and
she didn't give a [ __ ] and he said lady
if you don't shut the [ __ ] up I'm gonna
take my dick out and slap you in the
face with it
she goes you don't have the balls and he
goes I don't have the balls and he
starts going like that and the crowd's
going nuts thinking he's joking yeah all
I remember was his helmet sticking out
from his fist
and he just put it in her face and made
these machine gun noises [ __ ]
[ __ ] she didn't even
went ballistic yeah went [ __ ]
ballistic God could you imagine today I
can't imagine because I had to go up
next in the house well I'm not gonna say
was like what the [ __ ] was that goddamn
we're gonna keep this show going
keep it going it's right through it but
Billy Bird I [ __ ] went right up after
that and went into my act and it was one
of the it wasn't even like bombing it
was like I was doing my act and they
were in another club they were just
talking like they couldn't believe what
happened I still couldn't yeah how could
you I've never heard of that in
even I haven't heard anything come close
to that
a dude pulling his dick out
all right it's simply safe everybody did
you know did you know that property
crimes like burglaries and package thex
thefts Spike over the winner winner
winner
that's why now is the best time to
secure your home with award-winning home
security yeah and catch those those
porch Pirates whatever they what do they
call them there where they take the
[ __ ] packages Simply Safe is the home
security system I recommend to everybody
make it your resolution to start the new
year with greater peace of mind and
safety for you and your family here's
why I love it SimpliSafe was named the
best home security system of 2022 by U.S
news and World Report a third year in a
row in an emergency 24 7 Professional
monitoring agents use fast protect
technology exclusively from SimpliSafe
to capture critical evidence and verify
that the threat is real so you get
priority police response
Simply Safe as a whole home security
with Advanced sensors and for every room
window and door HD security cameras for
inside and out smarter ways to detect
motions uh motion that alert you only
when a threat is real and even Hazard
sensors that detect fires floods and
other threats to your home 24 7
Professional monitoring service costs
under a dollar a day less than half the
price of adt's traditional
professionally installed system Jesus
crisis is a lot of information with the
top rated SimpliSafe apps stay in
complete control of your home system
anytime anywhere arm or disarm unlocked
for a guest access your cameras or
adjust your system settings customize
the perfect system for your home in just
a few minutes at simplysafe.com
simplisafe.com go today and claim a free
indoor security camera plus
plus plus plus 20 off your order with
interactive monitoring that's
simplysafe.com
there's no safe like SimpliSafe all
right I'm this is bad edit I'm not gonna
lie to you I just told some stories that
uh you can't [ __ ] someday
someday someday when we're both retired
yeah I just don't want it doesn't matter
anymore yeah I didn't name any names did
I you didn't name anybody I just named
body parts yeah
and not even in vague locations vague
locations yeah vague locations and body
parts that's gonna be my name and my
memoir
I'm very excited I I got this jacket
back after a year we lost it no I was I
went to the Rose Bowl with Joe bartnick
and I left it in his truck and I finally
got it back after a year yeah we just
always meant to I go over his house I
forgot the jacket so hold on that that
jacket's been stewing in like bartnick's
it was in his truck and yeah and it was
like covered in dog hair and all that
[ __ ] he took a cut to he got it he got a
[ __ ] dry cleaned he should because he
knows
he knows it's a hot box whatever that
car that he's driving it's just odors
and loud you would think you would think
I would know I'll tell you one time he
he's like hey man
come over we're gonna do the podcast I
go great he's he's like be there at noon
I go great looking forward to it we're
both in Pasadena Drive over by the way
you guys are my two favorite Pittsburgh
guys this is gonna break my heart here
what happens this is what he does ready
this is this is what you don't want this
is what you don't want when you're going
over to a podcast like today it's like
you show up okay we're starting on time
here we go bartnick opens the door hairs
[ __ ] up he's in a tank top shorts
Barefoot he goes first thing he says to
me you're not in a rush are you I'm like
oh [ __ ] here we go
[ __ ] bundle of wires he's [ __ ] I
don't know where the [ __ ] this goes
where's the Purdue where is he's his
producer's not there barefoot [ __ ]
Daniel brush his teeth yet he just woke
up and he's [ __ ] trying to plug [ __ ]
in I'm just like [ __ ] I could be
home right now you could have told me
another 45 whatever that's that's how he
starts the [ __ ] podcast is that what
it means you're not in a hurry is that
what made you leave La was that the
final thing that was it that was the
straw that broke the camel's back yeah
way you are have you announced where you
are that people understand where you are
in the world nobody gives a [ __ ] all
right no nobody cares look at me being a
national
um okay all right I wasn't sure you know
I feel like that's your information no I
moved to Nashville uh because look I
mean you you know you live here and I'm
like getting to the point where I'm
gonna blame you for covet what's that
did they blame the locals did they blame
you for covid
I'll tell you this you get randomly
beaten up as you walk down the street I
go I go looking like Hank Williams and
it's like it's like [ __ ] 2 000 you
know when I moved there it's like 2017.
it's like nothing ever happened it's
like Mardi Gras right on on that
Broadway that's a great Street good
barbecue there too [ __ ] great and
then I come back to LA every now and
then this is like after I move and I'm
walking down the street I got my mask on
my wrist I'm in Venice going to a
restaurant to meet some friend
three people within two and a half
blocks yelled at me put on your [ __ ]
mask yeah not like hey put on your mask
put the same three there was people who
bought in that was he had a divided
locker room some people bought in other
people didn't and we didn't win the
championship
we all needed to be pulling in the same
direction and we just weren't nobody
yeah everybody everybody knew what the
[ __ ] people should be doing so and it's
just it's never going to work not now
you can't Corral the masses now with the
internet I I think that moment in time
I don't think it'll ever be replicated
again where you you really saw before it
was like you know somebody wore Maga had
it's like oh that that's really hard
right then that obviously that person is
hard but when the mask thing came about
that's when everybody was kind of forced
to show your cards
from Reagan like literally stole it make
America great again
yeah you think he's nothing against
he's a heck well it disappointed me I
was like honey how do you base your
whole campaign on some [ __ ] that was
already said although what's his face
Reagan said let's win one for the Gipper
yeah
all right let's get them all now what
did Clinton do you know he did some old
slick Willy well he's [ __ ] on an
island somewhere yeah oh yeah he was on
up he was too busy on Epstein Island to
come up did you see that painting of him
that Epstein had of Clinton I know it's
on the Internet Is that real it's got to
be real because it came out it can't be
it has to be I guarantee it is when
you're that
I think this is well I want to hear this
Theory when you're that rich when you're
that rich they let a guy do a painting
of you what is the painting of is him in
a dresser it's him like normal and he's
in a he's in a chair and then he's got
like a skirt and the heels like when
people get super [ __ ] Rich they don't
know how to accept uh the influx money
that's when they find crystals and God
and spirituality
I think those are the healthy ones the
people that aren't go the other way
you're on a [ __ ] Island you're
banging 13 year old Filipino girls
whatever flying in I think when you get
that much money it just one way or the
other it's one way or the other you just
find Jesus
dude you're gonna have you're gonna have
crystals on your face in about two years
and go oh Billy's getting spiritual no
I'm not because what what saves me is my
wife I want to retire
I'm not gonna return early I just want
to get the yeah I just want to have the
ability that if this business is done
with me I'd be all right cool thank you
I had a great [ __ ] time and you know
I really love seeing I love seeing old
people sitting on a porch watching
people going by yeah you know I want to
do that I don't want to miss out on that
in life I I think I'm just worried that
newspapers won't exist anymore by the
time I get to that age
like they should just have them for old
people
to have for Nostalgia newspaper yeah
it's a great thing you sit there with a
cup of coffee you drink a new oh you say
that's over here what's going on there
in South Carolina
doing the crossword they didn't do that
when I was a kid oh yeah that's the best
[ __ ] ever you've said something like
this to me before though where you said
I I was congratulating you on something
and you're like yeah I'm not going to
say the person's name but just like you
were you were like you know look at XYZ
it could just be over like that and I
think you've always had this perspective
of
uh yeah I I think of like the marathon
mindset as opposed to sprinters
yeah no I just I I you know what you
want you know what puts this business
into perspective go watch a a an Oscar
taping if you can [ __ ] sit through it
from like 10 years ago no you don't
remember there will literally be people
that are presenting at the Oscars going
like who the [ __ ] is that you don't even
know who they are yeah well they were
they were there on the biggest night in
Show Business
um I know does it even matter anymore I
don't think it matters but I think will
there ever be one worse than the covid
one
when Glenn Close tried to act like she
knew who [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] that
rapper was oh oh God that was so planned
that was just one of the oh you know I
know exactly I was in the scene man
I was just like ah just why can't you
just say no I didn't I was I was doing
Jane Fonda workout tapes I'm a white
chick
I was doing white [ __ ]
well I think this is the best line about
Hollywood I've ever come across it's
Orson Welles
Citizen Kane amberson's obviously one of
the greatest films of all time if not
the and
just ostracized by the Hollywood
Community and his line as he's talking
kind of a [ __ ] wasn't he
I think there were Ebbs and flows of it
yeah but he Peter bogdanovich wrote this
book about conversations he had with
them is it called the bearded [ __ ] or
some Well story
but his line was uh all roads in Los
Angeles lead to the airport
and I was like yeah if you go that way
they well but but eventually I think
most women lead them in and out too
the good ones yeah but eventually
they're going to be done with you
eventually they're done with everybody
eventually you're in you're in the party
every [ __ ] business people in Show
Business gotta be stopped so being so
[ __ ] melodramatic about the fact you
know nobody wants an 80 year old plumber
okay you're done well I I everybody
we have 80 year old everybody running
the country right now is in their
[ __ ] 80s pelosiers they're [ __ ]
lizards yeah
I love Allah see who else who else you
got how much
can you name all the starting Trump
Schumer's a comic
I'm not going to go there you went you
went from [ __ ]
politicians to comedians Chuck Schumer
oh that's right yeah he's [ __ ] up
there he doesn't they're all up there
I I dude I honestly I don't pay
attention
his name's Chuck Chuck Schumer all right
out of New York
he's been there forever
sounds like a division three football
player to me plowing ahead all right we
had to cut out some more [ __ ] Steve
Barnes It's just bringing the danger
bringing the danger I thought you all
you Nashville people I thought you guys
you know can't say something nice you
you don't say nothing at all that's
right yeah you just put on a hood and go
light up across right I love when Betty
when Joan Joan Crawford passed and then
Betty Davis you're half white right yeah
could you have could you get like a
junior membership into the clan if you
stay in Nashville long enough unless
you're a junior yeah and listen to like
you can never be like you remember how
like I get the skank shift I could go to
this [ __ ] on Friday or Saturday
come on in oh if you want 100 Italian
you couldn't get in the mob yeah so
you're not 100 white like but there's
got to be they can still use you look
their numbers are dwindling they could
they need some fresh blood foreign
look what we did we converted this guy
and he's half the the amount of things
that are going out of business that you
just never thought you'd add the clan to
it I just always thought there'd be
enough idiots
to put on sheets and stand in the
[ __ ] Woods
you know you know what it is Steve
people want to belong to something they
want to feel like they belong I always
thought it was so crazy how like when
the clan why'd you join the clan I don't
know man I was lonely got myself a big
piece of property it's what I thought I
wanted just wanted some friends I could
hear them Bullfrogs and crickets every
night I got lonely one night I went to a
party turned out on the party
I love those [ __ ] places though I
make fun of the South Coast why wouldn't
you yeah you know what I mean I'm not
gonna sit there and pretend I have
respect for them sure all right I like a
winner the north no
um
no I I like I like the pace down there
it is a slower Pace like everybody
always shits on Alabama I love Alabama
why do you like Alabama
I just divide man dude if you go through
there and you put on Tom Petty uh
Louisiana rain forget about it yeah
you're gonna go but you're gonna buy a
house you wanna be an old person you
want to sit on a porch you want a people
watch I am not afraid of Aging I'm not
I'm not either I love either I can't
wait to play the [ __ ] grandfather
that has three lines on a sitcom
[Laughter]
you know where I'll be and you put the
thing on the thing and go right in the
bathroom
I guess it's my bedtime
do that in a minute have a nice opioid
[ __ ] problem
um so tell me about this special where
did you shoot it
shot it in Nashville
shot at Nashville I've always wanted to
shoot a special in the city that I live
in and just go to the best I didn't have
to get on a plane that's fantastic and
uh yeah I just did this special it's
called the last late night it's an
homage to the late night talk show I
felt like there's you know there's a lot
of great specials out there but for me
I was always like well I just keep doing
the same [ __ ] I got to do something a
little bit different so so I was
watching a late night talk show I was
like you really think about three styles
of writing it's monologue one-liners
then panel storytelling and then
traditional stand up I thought oh that'd
be kind of cool do that on the set 20
minutes 20 minutes 20 minutes and so I
inserted commercial breaks have a live
have a live oh yeah oh you got a whole
concept a concept album for you a
concept of them and it looks and there's
an actual theme to it it all comes down
to something at the end uh where I kind
of make my case it took five years
because I had to learn how to do people
think oh you're just a comic just go
roast that person or just just do crowd
work or just improv it's like
Jeff Ross is great at roasting he's
really great at roasting but like he
worked on it like you got to work on
these muscles so the monologue stuff I
asked Argus Hamilton to help me out he
helped me out a ton with it and so after
like years of like of of understanding
how to write it and using him as a
crutch then I was like oh I I think I
got the hang of it now so I was able to
do the arithmetic on yeah those
monologue jokes are hard it's not
there's no fat on those jokes at all one
writing job doing that oh what show was
it that was for the ESPYs
uh I'm sure you would have crushed it
though you're such a big Sports guy in
you but it's a different you know what I
mean it's a different way too and this
is like on network TV so like so much of
the subject matter so much of the stuff
was just no no for the 80th time you
can't say [ __ ] no no it wasn't even that
it was just uh you know you were dealing
with networks and then you're also
dealing with the images of the leagues
right right they're super protective of
yeah because I remember you know a long
time ago I wanted to do something for
the NFL and they thought we were making
fun of the fan base of a team
right too much uh we were we we sort of
shot like a Sizzle reel outside uh the
Oakland Coliseum at a Raiders game right
and you know all these people like you
know you got like the real fans and
people that dress up all crazy and [ __ ]
so what we do is I would go over to the
person dressed up crazy and I would be
talking about the Rays like yeah the
Raiders and all that and gradually I
would switch the topic to something more
serious you know like global warming or
like foreign policy and then they would
be standing there they would actually
have the conversation with you you got a
guy with all the makeup and the horns
you know I think it's more of a federal
issue right
and it was just silly yeah it was silly
because what you were actually showing
was the person behind the character they
sort of dropped the I got him to drop I
was getting them to drop the character
Persona you see who they were right
Monday through Saturday right and that
was just the bid it was harmless it was
just funny you should see them one of
the guys ended up being like a [ __ ]
scientist and he had this amazing these
Amazing Ideas he was actually working on
it and he was one of those guys that
dressed up it was a [ __ ] great little
piece yeah but they were worried that it
was going to come off as like mean
Spirit you were making fun of him so I
was writing on a show like within the
parameters like there's so much [ __ ]
money with those people and they're just
casting you know they're commercial
fishing
what they pull in that's like you know
yeah that's like that Colin Kaepernick
[ __ ] right where like enough people said
they didn't like him taking a knee and
then they were like well Races by
jerseys too so they sided with the
racist and then they ended up looking
stupid and then they had to be like well
wait a minute we we championed all kinds
of thought like they would just they
whatever the [ __ ] depends they went like
Don King have you seen that classic Don
King thing where he goes into the fight
with one fighter hyping him up oh yeah
the dude gets knocked out and then he
leaves the fight with the other fighter
yeah that's what they do it was [ __ ]
Russian Rocky IV yeah so like
that's what you were writing for so it
was it ended up being like a lot I got
one joke I think I did or maybe verzie
got it in yeah was that that one I can't
remember I did one with uh was writing
with bartnik so we were sitting there
laughing our balls off writing this [ __ ]
and then we handed it in to the woman
that was running and they're like nah we
can't use any of this stuff
and I was like all right let's go let's
go PG-13
I can't use any of this stuff oh my God
yeah so
well they were still spooked from Norm
they were still bringing up Norm rest no
way really yeah I mean
you know I I think that's that's another
reason why it like look an hour special
is an hour special but I wrote this
Steve can you promote the goddamn thing
can you be excited about it I I am very
excited about it but this is this all
roads leave the Steve Burns special
was I I was like watching Carson over
and over again and like Bob Hope and
dangerfields and and Dean Martin I was I
was like studying them and then I got to
a point I was like well that's
every political satire show every late
night talk show
is not just left I think it's hard left
and I'm absolutely is now it is but back
in the day back in the day it wasn't so
I thought why not take more of a
Centrist perspective and hit somebody
would do that and I don't want to know
who you [ __ ] voted for I don't give a
[ __ ] Robert Hartman who we both know he
he pulled Messiah afterwards he said I
still don't know politically where you
align yourself and I'm like thank you
that was the best compliment I got yeah
but then all the jokes I had that were
geared towards the right hitting a
little hard on the left
those are the ones those those 12 were
the ones that didn't make it in and I
was I was pissed I was like that's the
whole point of this is to have
you know not tip the scales one way or
the other and so if you watch it the
scales are tipped a little bit more like
a traditional stand-up show present day
that's annoying I I Furious about it no
I yeah okay those are liberals
[Laughter]
oh they [ __ ] uh they edit what the
[ __ ] you say dude it's it's a really uh
you know I I don't know I used to think
I was liberal now I don't I don't know
what it is I just
um what do you think it is I'm becoming
a separatist like I just don't want to
be around any of that [ __ ] talk I
don't give a [ __ ] right and what do I
think what is
well I I think when you say I don't know
what being a liberal is
I wonder because I I know what it is
what it used to be liberal was you were
open-minded yeah and but there's a thing
but but I always felt though yeah that
there was a time to be open-minded and
there was a time to be like hey you know
what I mean let's [ __ ] play it a
little closer to the vest it's just it's
like anything it's it's all how you
apply it so
um
yeah I mean I don't know you know like I
was talking to my podcast all right
capitalism has passed me by okay once
you get to be my age it's just done with
you right you're not buying enough [ __ ]
you're not playing the game right they
they walk you out of the casino bill
that's why I can't just sit here with
your rum and coke you got to put some
money on the table after a while at
least get a [ __ ] hooker I get the
[ __ ] out of the casino that's basically
what it is so I'm basically now
I'm out on the board Christmas
is the magic show
thank you oh I'm on my way to uh
for the uh Nicholson I like it I like it
I like hanging with my kids I like
hanging with my wife and uh but I am you
know I'm taking a little break from the
road but I'm writing a whole bunch of
new [ __ ] for when I go back out in April
which I'm really excited about because
that's the part of the business though
that has never gotten old for me is I
love going on the road I love doing
stand up I love being a [ __ ] idiot
like last night I was just being a
[ __ ] idiot why do I understand what
club I just Place The Bourbon Room or
something like that it's a new place um
and I was just being a [ __ ] idiot I
was just saying so much stupid [ __ ] and
the crowd knew sure I'm telling you dude
there's a new Vibe out there it's not
like you know oh my God you know Dad's
home vibe that was it's been going off
like hey this is more open at this point
they kind of want to see you be like uh
an idiot and that's all I was doing like
you know yeah I'll tell she got off easy
just doing stupid [ __ ] like that and
just you know and them getting that I'm
just saying that of course the
over-the-top I obviously don't feel
these things and they were laughing so
it's just egging me on and then you
start hearing the comics laugh and then
you start chasing those laughs and then
you just end up talking yourself into
these [ __ ] you know like all those
like all that [ __ ] that happens late
night at the store and all of that it
was like it was like one of those sets
and
then of course I did another show and
then the big thing there is don't think
about the first show but I was thinking
too much about the first show and it
took me a little bit longer
to get into it I've just learned that
over the years it's just like you have a
[ __ ] amazing feels like magical show
yeah best thing to do is forget that
even [ __ ] happened and go but you
don't you're like but on the first show
I said this and people left here
announced down here and then it just
slowly the roulette wheel again it
doesn't matter what you what you said
and then you come out going oh my God I
[ __ ] hate myself but um this [ __ ]
guy man you had so many incidents in
this business yeah I remember The Comedy
Store not I mean the comic strip yeah
somebody threw a chair at you yeah eight
Staples in the back yeah yeah he had
eight Staples in the back of his head
and somebody actually put Staples on it
on my headshot his head shop out of the
frame put Staples on them and put it
back in yeah you just will always like
bobby shows the video who you know if if
I had to guess somebody's gonna get a
chair thrown at them like you would have
been one of the guys I'm like you walk
in everybody's got their head down it's
like what happened to burn what yeah
yeah and the thing was you didn't have
like a mean act that's what I couldn't
understand yeah she had a temper
well I you look I got that Irish fire I
got that green fire though no it's all
about that it's both yeah what are you
Korean Korean has it's everybody that's
just [ __ ] laid back oh in Korea yeah
uh no it's called Han so it's like the
it's like it's basically nobody has a
temper in Korea you're just gonna put
that all on oh they uh 100 do do you
know I finally it's worse than coming
down Koreans are known as the Irish of
Asia that's always been like the subtext
whiskey potatoes drinking singing
fighting all of it yeah do you know I
haven't answered an Irish comic the
other night he finally explained to me
what happened in the Potato Famine I
just thought they planted too many times
in the same area and they ran out of
potatoes the [ __ ] British took their
potatoes it was like a genocide and they
killed like two and a half million of
them really I always thought that that's
what he said he had a [ __ ] broke so I
believed it I didn't look it up yeah he
said it I listened and I just repeatedly
okay it's fact yeah all right now that's
out there now I know and it took me 48
years to learn about it and I'm wearing
a colada ring that's how bad I take all
the potatoes
I don't know how you take it you know
why they were all Irish while I'm
drinking the night before
British got their own I'm sorry
um so people can watch this on Amazon
yeah Amazon Prime last late night look
it's just fun it's different it's it's
very different but it's a lot of fun a
lot of work went into it and again I
think like
now it's almost like the reason why
you're like oh next out it's like I I
don't know how you feel about our Circle
get back to wearing a pirate's hat
you're a pirates fan now huh
come on I've been to some games yeah of
course I mean I'll always root for him
but there's nothing there's stadiums in
the league it's just bad ownership it's
horrible ownership horrible there's it's
like what to root for it's like a
beautiful day at the park I mean that's
what you're rooting for I hope it
doesn't rain today sun goes down
that's As Good As It Gets
but it is a great Park to watch a game
and a hundred percent I just what could
the fans do
to force the sale would you just have to
stop going
but I think even just TV Revenue alone
he'll he'll be don't don't you break
even on TV Revenue who's your owner is
it Mr burn
s Bob nutting I think it's his last name
can he go out in Pittsburgh
I don't think he doesn't even live in
Pittsburgh I don't I I know he's been to
some games and some fans have shown up
with like shirts [ __ ] on him in
front and he takes the picture and then
it's on Instagram he's like oh
[ __ ] so he doesn't really he's
very selective about who he takes
pictures with oh yeah it's one of those
things that's a shame dude I'm still
1979 the We Are Family Pirates that's
one of my that might be my favorite
world series of all time really it was
just fun yeah they were down 3-1 they
came back Earl Weaver and the Orioles
had those very colorful you know the
uniforms back then that yellow really
popped even on the old school TVs sure
and that orange of the uh the uh the
Orioles yeah we had Eddie Murray and
they had Jim Palmer you guys had John
Candelaria the Candyman right Daryl
Porter
Kent to Covey I remember all those guys
Omar Moreno right
Tina Fey at second base what was his
name
it's like Tim Foley that's right I know
it's the same initials yeah but Three
Rivers was was uh not a great place to
watch a game and so I'm glad that this
was a fight it was awful by the time I
got there that place was a [ __ ] I
saw a pirates game I saw Willie Stargell
make one of his final public appearances
there it was against the uh
um uh the Cubs yeah so I had uh right
field mine Sammy Sosa was right there
and um Willie Stargell came up there I
never saw a Steelers game there which
would have been iconic
yeah but it was like to me it was always
like the greatest example of how much
white people love concrete it was like
there was so much concrete are we
talking about everybody loves concrete
concrete's everywhere yeah so why are
you putting that on us
you build everything
we do yeah I thought we told other
people to do it then we took credit here
we go edit that out why I'm leaving that
in talking about brown people
is that what you're talking about am I
talking about that yes you are all right
the tea leaves
what's wrong with that I'm taking my
jacket off oh well we'll get bait are we
gonna bring the [ __ ] sell a table
back oh what are we doing here no this
just got I got excited so I want to keep
wearing my jacket he just got too hot
Jesus Christ I look like a [ __ ]
melted snowman you look fantastic
um that was but but do you think in
terms of our specials that they mean as
much as even see if I am trying my God
damn this to promote this [ __ ] no no
I'm asking you you're you're going gloom
and doom on me
I'm asking you like I think they mean
the same as they've always met that if
you have one of the best ones that's
going to do something for you if it's
it's not going to do anything for you
yeah
that's it or if they see you and you
[ __ ] kill but then when you go to
their Town you're doing the exact same
material right yeah you [ __ ] yourself
again
I just think
it's almost like you were doing that
toast you know when you lock arms with
people the way you went around the thing
um yeah so that I I always I've always
believed in uh
I remember I saw this interview Seinfeld
said one time he goes you know the the
comedy ecosystem always purifies itself
the cream's gonna rise to the top and
that's hat that has to be how you think
yeah because when you're coming up you
know the guy with the silly hat or the
[ __ ] catchphrase or the [ __ ] hot
yeah yeah yeah or the [ __ ] they got a
hook man they got a [ __ ] Orca oh my
crazy [ __ ] Appalachian wedding or
whatever right they build a [ __ ] show
and all those people are getting the
attention right you just got to stay the
course like dude I remember going to
like comedy festivals
sitting at tables with Comics now some
of the biggest Comics out there like
none none of them yeah could get anybody
to even [ __ ] look at them and they
were all going after uh you know they
they
it was weird Cosby Show came out and
that became a big hit
and then Roseanne came out and then that
became a big hit and then Seinfeld and
then I just think everybody it just
became that's what you got to do you got
to work totally clean and then you got
to get it right right yeah yeah blah
blah and then everybody got into that
must-see TV thing and uh it got really
um
it didn't get safe it's just they just
kept picking but I don't mean like Safe
People Doom and Gloom I just I just
think in the overall scheme of
entertainment and content they're so
[ __ ] much and like we're here talking
about the state of comedy with Steve
bird but I think I honestly think it's
like you people don't realize the Sweat
Equity the time the bandwidth that goes
into something and then it's it's a
firework in the sky people go oh it's
[ __ ] great and then you just move the
[ __ ] on before that happens I think if
you connect with them remember that guy
that that Latino dude drinking the beer
on the [ __ ] skateboard with the
Fleetwood Mac playing in the background
that was just everybody connected with
that guy that guy was [ __ ] cool as
[ __ ] he had the right song right he kind
of reminded everybody to [ __ ] sit
back and enjoy life or whatever yeah
yeah that guy is not a comedian he's not
even in this [ __ ] business right all
right but he made something great
and everybody saw it yeah I believe that
I don't give a [ __ ] if there's nine
million netflixes I really believe if
you make something [ __ ] great yeah
it's not a firecracker in this guy
I still have hope I still have the pilot
light still on in here you wouldn't know
it yep
okay I know I look like an old house but
I'm telling you
the furnace is still pumping yeah stay
s you're out there and you're with you
no people man yeah you're out there in
the real America with the real peoples
yeah where you can wave a Confederate
flag and no one will just don't mean
nothing means something different to
everybody in Tennessee
it really does yeah but I I've heard the
n-word more
in like New York and Chicago and L.A you
know going back to New York and just
going to the clubs I hear right New York
Chicago yeah never here I haven't heard
it in in the South not even in a
Careless Whisper I haven't heard
anything veiled or slightly racist or
anything and it's always that stigma but
I just haven't been maybe I just haven't
been around it I don't know maybe
not people
and I don't know what experience you're
looking for there and I'm sure you could
find it Well the Nashville I think at
Nashville I think is kind of listen dude
do you think I really think that there's
more racist people in the that one of
the biggest [ __ ] [ __ ] thing is
that all the racist white people are in
the South and in Boston
it's not true if you've done the [ __ ]
road it's just uh
why does Boston get such a bad thing
busting story went National and then
that was it it's like the [ __ ] people
to this day think that Lake Erie caught
on fire outside of Cleveland it didn't
it was an inlet it was a little [ __ ]
area right there was some you could
[ __ ] do that anywhere they'd had some
[ __ ] oil and [ __ ] and somebody threw
a [ __ ] cigar in there and they called
a mistake by the lake everybody's like
the [ __ ] Lake caught on fire it
wasn't the lake
it was it was a little yeah it was in
you know where the old improv was yeah
yeah I don't know if it's still there I
never played that place the Cleveland
Brown it was like you know that there
was like whatever I'm not a sailor I
don't know what you call it but it's
you're not out there right right yeah
you know if you got a good [ __ ]
breath you could probably swim from one
side to the other that's the part that
caught on fire so that's what happens
it's like uh you know Philly's forever
gonna be oh they they threw [ __ ]
batteries at that that Santa Claus right
and blah blah blah blah that's all they
talk oh my God those fans are [ __ ]
crazy it's like they're crazy people get
killed out here
yeah that's just not a fun story
to be like he was wearing a Giants
uniform Jersey and he was with his kids
and he got kicked in the head till he
had brain damage and five years later he
died see it's not as funny right right
he's not a ring to it yeah so Philly is
looked at as the worst [ __ ] fans yeah
they're not they're like they got they
have they have more of a frat vibe
we're out here like a hairy frat vibe
I don't know I'll be honest with you I
don't know anything about Philly I did
that stupid rant everybody thought I
knew everything but I don't know
anything about it
other than that they have an
unbelievable amount of one-way streets
going in the same direction before the
next one comes
that's all I know and you just like is
this the one is this the one where I
finally get to go nope no I don't nope
not at all no I don't and I also know
that route 95 avoids it and I think
that's it's a really
it's amazing yeah that it avoids it it's
a major city and then it's just because
I really think
that 95 not they didn't I don't know who
they did in Greece but that just goes
right past them down to [ __ ] DC oh
yeah yeah and I feel like that has
always made them
be considered that's why you can never
get a direct flight there was one direct
flight from LA to Philly forever that
[ __ ] U.S Air flight and that goddamn
Browning purple airplane that was a
pittsburgh-based airline I believe US
Airways uh yeah
but
Hollywood's kind of the same too
as far as what like I know you have the
101 on one side but it's kind of
landlocked
Yeah by all kinds of conservatives and
gun owners and [ __ ] that's what's funny
everybody thinks out everybody's out
here gender neutral bathrooms
transgender people they think
everybody's it's like if you're
underneath the Hollywood sign
you get out to Burbank and all Inland
Empire we're beside all of that [ __ ]
that all those beaches by the way
underneath the Hollywood sign that Gower
exit where you go to like uh UCB and all
that stuff Have You Been There recently
no it's [ __ ] crazy how disgusting
that is and there's like a lot of
affluent people that live right off that
exit right up into the hills oh why
don't we help those people a lot of them
are veterans do you know a lot of those
people who are living underneath that
[ __ ] Bridge a few years ago were
getting cheered halftime in an NFL game
then they come out the other side of the
military you think it's all like vets
there's a lot of vets down there yeah
yeah
I I don't know I don't know the
breakdown I'd love to know what I don't
know who's polling the homeless bugs
well you got all prickly there didn't
you
get it you left LA and now you're going
to come back and [ __ ] on it like this
was a clean City when you were here it
wasn't I look I lived the city shouldn't
even exist
it's a desert it's a there's no palm
trees palm palm trees don't exist here
they're all forced to be here they had a
dream
palm trees are going to make it big and
they came out to L.A they have a right
to dream too yeah and a lot of them made
it to Beverly Hills there's no water
here in 10 years okay great yep
there's no water specials don't mean
anything
specials what are we doing here how it
kills me today is the amount of rain
that went down the LA River right out
into the [ __ ] ocean and they don't
save one drive every year they're like
don't take a shower
listen I'm gonna tell you what let me
tell you somebody dude I'm going down
with the ship out here you you you're
hitching your
I don't give a [ __ ] can I tell you
something Steve if you're gonna sit in
Nashville and watch La fall into the
ocean and you want to continue into that
world I don't I root for La I root I
don't I don't wanna I don't want to see
I don't want to see Miami under [ __ ]
water no but thank God I don't [ __ ]
live there I'm not one of those people
that left is like man [ __ ] L.A like I
still love La I mean I spent I said one
good thing about it talking about dirty
people on Gower you're saying all
[ __ ] roads lead to to the airport
that was the industry you know what I'm
offended
well your special sounds interesting and
it doesn't sound like a [ __ ]
firecracker in the sky I think it could
do something for you well we'll see if
you turn that frown upside down yeah
what's going on out there man too many
belt buckles
how many people have told you you're one
of the good ones out there oh dude you
know how many times I hear that YouTube
Oh nailed it when I bam I like you Steve
you ain't like the other ones are you
yeah just kidding but also from you know
that don't you but also here when I come
back and I haven't seen people in quite
some time they go oh you're one of the
good ones man I know it's good to see
you too I like that I'll take that
compliment
but do they mean one of the good people
in this business I think so yeah you got
to do that math though right yeah and I
also should make it sound like it's
funny as I'm sitting there they go they
act like every every all the racism is
in South yeah and in Boston and every
time I do like a southern guy
I do the racist thing yeah it's just
always fun it's easy it's easy but it's
an accent
what's the worst accent you could you've
had to do
had to do okay I mean it's just
uh I did a British one on a on a Shores
on years ago it was it was oh God
didn't work for years after yeah I mean
I never booked any of the auditions
you know back then you just go yeah can
you do a Chicago accent oh yeah Mom get
some Pap put it in the Box oh geez so
combining [ __ ] Wisconsin it's funny I
went to uh when I did Fargo I remember
them all saying that going like you know
we don't talk like that you know
everybody always makes a point it's like
well you know well my wife is from
Minnesota and she's like we don't talk
like I'm like you're talking like it
right now like you have the accent
there's elements of it yeah I will say
though the the Boston accent I I love
listening to people doing it trying to
do it and every once in a while somebody
like gets it like I just watched the
verdict yeah Sydney lament with uh Paul
Newman Paul Newman right and uh
and some of the Boston accents and
they're just wild like going like like
actory Boston no they just were just bad
where they just go uh
oh now seeing caught
instead oh you know that's cool because
they they think everything's car park so
they go cat this is right Court
you just say the word without the I've
been for years I've been trying to help
people out yeah you just you say the
word like you'd normally say it just
take the r r out court court court
I [ __ ] see you in court dude
have you ever seen 13 days with Kevin
Costner
it it could be you might find it
offensive how I don't I don't because I
know I'd add my accents do
you have like my Irish English and
Scottish it's all just it's a mismatch
Australian in there I can only say one
word and it with an Irish dialect is oh
you [ __ ] [ __ ] that's it and I learned
it from Mark Hayes because I watch him
yeah Khan that's it
yeah I I can only say what was said to
me back I can't do it and then just like
pick it up I guess I could if I like
lived there long enough yeah I remember
when I was making fun of women that get
that what time what time was this bill
uh it's a more playful time and I was
making fun of women that have that
shorter I told the story on Bobby's
podcast with you know
once your wife has a couple two three
kids she gets that haircut you know she
doesn't want to deal with it anymore
right yeah first time you bend her over
you feel like you're [ __ ] your friend
Eric
whatever it's a cute joke yeah and in
the end you know I was signing whatever
the [ __ ] I was saying you know trying to
get a Following over there and I looked
up and there was a woman with like short
hair and she just looked at me she just
goes was this the haircut you were
talking about
oh yeah yeah actually it was it was I
didn't say I was like oh no it looks
good
I hated that I didn't just admit to it
like yes yeah you know it was of course
yes she and she's got that that heat
when you're in the audience knowing
she's talking about that Irish anger
yeah I have nothing to lose yeah that
was a wild trip I went I was uh did uh
Belfast up there man like that that's
one of the places I will never the
[ __ ] vibe in that City still right
this from the troubles which is so
classic Irish
you know I mean like if you don't even
know what the word holocaust meant that
just sounds like something horrific
happened yeah the troubles is just so
underplayed well I don't respect on the
troubles and it's yeah they like
kneecapping each other [ __ ] taking
people out families I mean I mean I
shouldn't even talk because I don't even
know what the [ __ ] sure but all I knew
was it every Irish guy that I met in
Belfast that was like about eight to ten
years older than me their [ __ ] Vibe
was like you could just you just you
just you immediately went to their
energy of like I'd come in like hey
great to be here how you doing yeah yeah
just like they had just like
like whatever they had been through like
it was just one of those things man you
could just uh um
I mean it was great crowd it was great
[ __ ] place attention
um yeah yeah and they still had that
wall up I I I I uh this guy he was
actually suggested a book to read but
there's just something about now that I
have kids I just can't I used to be able
to read [ __ ] like that I just can't read
[ __ ] of human beings doing horrible [ __ ]
to each other I can't do it anymore
becoming a softy I've watched too many
Pixar movies you know
yeah what's a good [ __ ] movie to get
me back to get get you back I used to
read all of the you know rape and Nan
King I would just sit there reading
these books yeah all these horrible
things that people have done to each
other but man it's tough to yeah I mean
like I saw the I saw Joker that Joker
movie uh Joaquin Phoenix it's
single-handedly the like I would watch I
would watch Million Dollar Baby as a
pick-me-up after that it was like this
movie's [ __ ] depressing and I
remember watching it going
I get it I appreciate it I'll never
watch this again I like I felt icky for
three days like ah [ __ ] I just want to
be nice to people after that I would say
Joaquin Phoenix crushed it
yeah he did right it killed it yeah but
it just the whole of those people that
makes me want to quit the business oh
yeah you start thinking you're starting
to get good at acting and then you watch
one of his movies this is like I think
Leonardo DiCaprio
and Once Upon a Time in Hollywood that's
my fifth that's my favorite one You Ever
Seen The Aviator The Aviator
just lose the r let's go see The Aviator
I never saw that one no I didn't he's
Howard Hughes and there's a scene where
he
he can't stop saying this one phrase
over and over again and he he slowly
devolving into he's losing his mind yeah
but he's looking syphilis or something
like that I don't know exactly what it
was but he's he's looked probably I mean
he banged like everybody
um literally Howard Hughes and Leonardo
DiCaprio but he's looking at himself in
the mirror and he's realizing he's going
crazy but he's crazy like you see it
it's just [ __ ] heartbreaking watching
that scene and I gotta see that it's
it's it's great it's really great the
performance I think is better than the
film and I still love the film
maybe that's a good one
I had to do the math on that
performance is still bet is better than
the film but I still like the film I
mean you [ __ ] went over the fence
like three times in that sentence
performance was better than the film but
I still like the films and I don't know
where the film is I like the film but he
is so good in that that guy crashed like
like three different planes I think yeah
something like that and he was the first
to take on TWA and not not TWA consider
yourself the Howard Hughes of comedians
would you I I would no not at all right
you don't model yourself after a white
guy
I had pneumonia
great to be here in this confined room
with you no I had it I had it how long
ago
like a month ago and then you know and I
went to uh find what's really up with
pneumonia.net and I got some uh
I got some pills off of that website
great I feel I feel good thanks I can't
wait to I went I went to a [ __ ]
Urgent Care did you really urgent care
talk to the doctor dude he [ __ ]
hooked me up so wait when did you start
feeling better
up like you know a couple weeks ago no
a couple days after Christmas oh [ __ ]
here we go
here we go now I gotta rely on you I'm
kind of feel a cold sweat right now
great no kidding let's just open mouth
kiss what are you talking about you go
to Nashville you guys don't wear masks
out there nobody where nobody wears a
mask anymore what about bandanas do you
guys have them around
let me go rob a cheater yeah the cool
the cool covet mask I mean Nashville's
not really Tennessee anymore is it
Nashville itself I don't think so I
think it's very uh Cosmopolitan yeah
very open-minded all right very
Progressive well the leadership is very
Progressive uh the mayor is yeah of
Nashville I know that do you get
offended when a restaurant has Asian
infused
it's like why couldn't you accept all of
us yeah you know yeah the whole by the
way Indians are not Asian I'm just
saying that on the record
when people think of India they are Asia
because but it's not there is what are
they think of the top three you think
Japan Korea
China well Canadians aren't American
even though they are part of North
America sure we're all considered a
member but Indians I don't consider you
don't consider oh yeah well I'm sure all
one billion of them are [ __ ] care on
what you think
where do you cut off
Asia where does Asia begin and end with
you there's Japan Korea the white people
of Asia right yeah the cute ones then
then no they're the ones who think that
the the the chosen once yeah right and
then you got what'd you say Koreans are
the the Irish well you guys break down
Asia into European countries China is
let me guess
China I was England
England I was gonna go to Germany really
oh well yeah well Japan
would be Germany
okay
oh yeah
I've read some books
look bill I believe in my hour special
that's my point okay all right all right
but uh Filipinos that's like a it's like
a minor league affiliate no yeah no man
that's like [ __ ] Mediterranean they
know how to live Beautiful People that's
the Mediterranean of you the happiest
the happiest one of the happiest
countries I've ever been to In My Life
dude you go all along the Mediterranean
everybody that they know how to [ __ ]
live yeah
the anger is up north I was in the
Philippines on a on a USO tour with Roy
Wood Jr
you know there's Japanese those like
Decked Out cabs there's people in the
cab there's people on top of the cab
there's people hanging on the cab like
hanging on the outside please do that
garbage trucks but I saw a guy hanging
off a guy hanging off the thing and we
were both like what the [ __ ] is going on
here but everybody was so it's called
what's that of course strength that's
right yeah he was just clinging to a guy
he was clinging to the guy his legs too
he was holding on to the
guy's foot on something on like a bumper
but he was holding on to the guy
it's amazing yeah happy people
they are that's why I said Mediterranean
all right
Singapore
Singapore don't know
yeah one of those places yeah we don't
get involved in anything but Bubba's
little Banks here
well I think that the lion will beat you
with a stick
that'd be Taiwan don't you think
because Taiwan was the one where the
ganjo woman went
I don't know got your lady she [ __ ]
went from Australia she goes to Bali or
someplace yeah and has a whole boogie
board instead of boogie board it's all
weed and they're like is this your bag
she's like yeah they're like all right
we're gonna put you to death
oh [ __ ] yeah I never saw that well
that's not Switzerland that one will
make you never want to travel again well
it's what was it Midnight Express
yeah that's another one yeah that's
another thing too you can't travel with
people that [ __ ] smoke weed because
they'll do [ __ ] like that WNBA chick did
they forget man
you know and there's so many different
[ __ ] ways to have it yeah right
that's what's great about alcohol it's
in a can or in a [ __ ] bottle I guess
you can know it little ones but they got
they got gummies wait a minute they got
cologne I mean they got weed and [ __ ]
everything they're scratching when the
dog comes in the airport just get the
[ __ ] away from it yeah that's it by the
way you want to talk about you can't
travel to one of those hardcore
countries with anybody that even
remotely [ __ ] with weed but like paid
disparity between NBA and wa and NBA
it's like yeah shared weed I mean if
you're a true professional athlete I
think you got the hiring [ __ ] you got
Coke
you got some good [ __ ] on you do people
really do Coke anymore
athletes the athletes really do Coke you
know what I I don't I don't even know
many Comics that even drink anymore
that drink a lot of them Vape
well I think once weed became legal yeah
it's just such an easier [ __ ] high
man than [ __ ] you know the one thing
about drinking booze is you get you earn
it
you [ __ ] gotta get all these beers
down or you got to drink some gas you
really earn it we're like weed is just
kind of like and I never did it I never
got it maybe I should I don't know
until this kicks in it's like it's just
such a nicer way
to go and there's no hangover there's no
after effects from it depends on what
you do you can definitely can have like
uh way too much I went to do that you're
out in public and you don't want to talk
to anybody yeah I always just admit I
just people just look at me I just said
dude I'm just like I'm just like really
too high right now I'm doing oh and then
they just laugh and I go that's the best
way to get out of the paranoia
I don't even know what the paranoia is
about it's legal but you just [ __ ]
sitting there go online I'll tell you I
I was doing I did Bert's podcast two
days ago at 11 30. it's another sign of
Aging
you crossed your arms and you started
this because I'm not happy about what
I'm about to say you started this
sentence with I'll tell you I'll tell
you
go back in my day
you don't know this about me bill
um I like Old Man Steve 11 30 till 3 30
just drinking and then I was like [ __ ]
well I came here to do Lopez's podcast
wait 11 30 a.m a.m to 3 30 until 3 30.
came here to do George low I don't even
[ __ ] remember doing it I just
remember looking at George and like I
can't believe I'm in the room with
because I really respect him I think
he's fantastic and I've always heard
great things about him and he was so
kind but it's just like a blur and then
I went to eat and then I kept drinking
because I was like if I go to bed if I
go to my hotel I'm gonna pass out so I
should just have another drink what did
you have a shower improv yeah did my
sets that night
uh blotted and I haven't felt right
since and of course I mean it's been two
I never do that I never [ __ ] I never
date Ram it on stage twice in my 31
years just twice yep once I was never
like a New Year's you never went like a
little no
I I one time I was coming back from a
Yankees Red Sox game at the old Yankee
Stadium
and I was I didn't think I was drunk you
had a few Pops at the game yeah and I
didn't think I was drunk yeah and and uh
remember Maria shahada she's in uh
England now she had it she goes hey I
got somebody dropped out can you do this
spot and I was just like
dude I went on stage oh brutal that and
then and then one other time I was in
Kilkenny Ireland and then I was
embarrassed I was embarrassed about that
because I actually had a show it was the
wrap-up show right and again it's just
tasted so [ __ ] good yeah and I'm
hanging and I'm [ __ ] I went up there
and uh I did okay yeah and I should have
killed and it was a stupid move and the
whole thing was I went over there to be
seen to be brought back yeah and I went
up there and I I did one of the worst
things you can do other than bombing was
I got the job done
you didn't lose them right right
yeah they're still here yeah thank you
whatever your name is I've already
forgotten it keep it going for that guy
uh yeah you know what you know I find it
the anxiety the next day is a hundred
times worse for me now than it ever I
don't know what it is I don't know if
it's age but but I'll have some drinks
and then the next day
it's I I don't even have a hangover I
just had the anxiety of like having
drunk the last night and I'm like did I
do something stupid or bad or just
replaying everything they're just like
oh God and I I would I would never watch
that I like I I know if I watch that
George Lopez ATC you know the appearance
I'm like oh God I I know I'm gonna want
to [ __ ] eat a shotgun
foreign
well they're readily available in
Nashville Tennessee everywhere my real
estate agent had one I mean
crazy all right well yeah I enjoyed this
I enjoyed I do it I always enjoy
catching up hang out with you man and I
I'm so happy for you in your film I
honestly am I cannot wait to see this
and I think yeah we'll see we'll see
what happens no I think playing the game
now trying to figure out you know I
think the industry has been so scared to
do comedy
they're rebooting house party uh I saw
the trailers like I want to see that
yeah because I love oh my God back in
the day of course comedy yeah it's gonna
be great and they got all The Originals
coming back I think
um what else did I say I saw something
else that was out there you know
I root for [ __ ] Steve yeah this this
industry is too hard for any I I to see
somebody have something that's just like
I always root for especially Comics
because it's it's so [ __ ] hard unless
you hate them
very few I very few I hate yeah isn't
that great hates are strong yeah when I
was young there was Comics I hated and
now that I'm older it's just like it
doesn't it doesn't matter anymore it
doesn't matter anymore
I just don't have the energy you just
don't you hate some like no you know
what I instead of going with hate I just
go with a void
yeah yeah there's people I'm not going
to go on my way to say no I just avoid I
avoid because that's what the [ __ ] I
mean you don't have to get along with
everybody just [ __ ] you just be nice
you just don't be cordial yeah I love
avoiding
that's what I love about The Comedy
Store there's so many nooks and crannies
and doorways and stairways you can just
[ __ ] oh my God that is yeah you can
just
[Laughter]
um I gotta get out of here though man
all right I got some [ __ ] I gotta go
[ __ ] dude uh back home there uh thank
you so much for coming out thank you um
Amazon check out Steve tonight I'm
telling you I am late night very proud
of this and I think people enjoyed it
yeah I think they're going to be great
all right yeah I like you're getting a
little chromogony I like that no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no I
think I think my just my thing is just
you know I I think I don't want to get
into your childhood I'm trying to wrap
this up here let's talk about the
Holocaust
you know what did you say you know what
the thing is the thing is whatever it
was a classic old man intro all right
that's the Thursday afternoon just for
Friday Monday Morning podcast amazon.com
the last late night check out Steve
Burns new special that's it thanks a lot
have a great weekend you can't
hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it is the Monday Morning podcast for uh
Monday
January 12th I'm gonna guess no it's not
January 12th what the [ __ ]
well wait a minute the 17th is Saturday
Fridays the 16th 15 14 13 12. yeah it's
the [ __ ] 12th
I'm on the road and uh I gotta keep my
voice down here because I'm in the
[ __ ] hotel room and I don't feel like
as it always happens whenever I do a
podcast in the uh the hotel room this
somebody eventually knocks on the door
because I'm screaming [ __ ] too loud
you know
if I was screaming bastard that would be
fine okay but if I scream [ __ ] then all
of a sudden they start thinking about
NFL players in their bottom lips
quivering and they realize that they got
to get it right you've got to get it
right
gotta get it right and then they come up
here and then I have a [ __ ] problem
um so anyways
this is going to be my tone for the
[ __ ] week
um
I'm in New Orleans do you know what it
means to Miss New Orleans that's where
my baby goes
um got an acting gig out here for a
couple of days a couple of days
and uh yeah that's it anyways
um
do you guys watch the football this
weekend huh how exciting was the goddamn
football
this [ __ ] city is so [ __ ] shady
man I I love it but it's [ __ ] shady
I never been in a city where you feel
like it's Christmas and you could get
your [ __ ] throat slit at any second I
mean that is that is New Orleans
in a nutshell
that and there's not a vegetable to be
found in this city
um
anyways uh let's go with the the the
first thing first the uh the Packers
Cowboys game
all right
I get like the fact that that isn't
ruled a [ __ ] catch and I know
everybody's sick of at this point but I
don't give a [ __ ]
if I saw one more nerd who looked like
he could even catch a [ __ ] beach ball
underhanded
in a [ __ ] playroom explain to me why
watching Dez Bryant catch that ball and
then have it said it wasn't a catch I
was gonna [ __ ] throw the TV out the
way I wasn't gonna do that come on
I get sued you know I'm not that kind of
guy but
it's [ __ ] unbelievable
the guy this is what kills me about that
[ __ ] rule Dez goes up catches the
ball
runs three steps
and then because he's so [ __ ]
athletic he can he's got giant hands he
can hold the ball in one hand against
his wrist
as he goes down he has the presence of
mind to try to get it as close as he can
to the goal line
and hits the ground pops out and then
they go it's not a catch and every
[ __ ] thing about him catching the
ball is not admissible under the rule he
goes up catches the ball not admissible
moves it from one hand to another not
admissible as far as control runs three
steps you can't count the steps
it was like some Boss Hog [ __ ] right
then [ __ ] extends his arm he didn't
extend it far enough
and then he [ __ ] it hits the ground
and pops out of the ad no catch
I'm trying to wrap my head around that
[ __ ] rule that all of that all of Dez
Bryant catching that football is not
admissible
because
I don't know maybe maybe the rule is a
good rule because
as they're saying they want a clear-cut
definition of what is a catcher what
isn't a catch
I love that the ref thought it was a
catch and then then just supposed to be
like irrefutable evidence to like I'm
just gonna say the word evidence
evidence that that
I don't know I just I just [ __ ] blew
my mind like
when they caught the ball they gave it
to him let's just say the Cowboys punch
it in then then they were up what three
four whatever and then you get the
excitement of the Packers get the ball
back and Aaron Rodgers
and they got two minutes you got this
unbelievable end to the game as opposed
to wow wow
oh we're sorry what you just saw happen
didn't really happen
[ __ ] it that is I gotta tell you
that is the worst
I can't say it's the word like the tuck
Rule's the worst [ __ ] rule I ever
seen in my life and that's coming from a
Patriots fan the Tuck Rule is the
dumbest thing I've ever seen in my life
there was never a problem with they
don't think you know 90 of 10 even
before instant replay
was his arm going back or was it going
forward and that was either you know
incomplete pass or a fumble that whole
thing that but if you then tuck it
against you like a little [ __ ] loaf
of bread
that that becomes what a an incomplete
pass the dumbest [ __ ] rule I've ever
seen in my life and before you Raider
fans feel Vindicated that I'm saying
this know that you have a Super Bowl
trophy and I remind you this because you
guys are so busy dressing up like
[ __ ] Alice in Wonderland before you
go to the game
all right you bunch of theater majors
that you forget that Super Bowl 11 you
won that on a horrific roughing the
passer call they put the ball all the
way down on the one yard line
okay against the New England Patriots so
it evened out
okay
it evens out right so we have one that
we shouldn't have and you have one that
you shouldn't have so we're [ __ ] even
but Jesus Christ
and my Patriots had the biggest [ __ ]
win ever and I can't get over the fact
that they [ __ ] me as a fan and said
that that wasn't a catch and an exciting
end of that game and instead
see Howie Long how long look look pissed
he's like that's a [ __ ] catch exactly
it is a [ __ ] catch but now with these
new nerd rules
you can't count the steps why
he had it in his bolt of his hands you
can't count that
you can't count he extended his hand he
didn't extend it far enough
the [ __ ] Motors the guy have to Dez
Bryant basically got punished for having
gigantic hands and being athletic
you know what I mean because anybody
else would be so psyched they just got
the ball they would have [ __ ] tucked
it in and it would have been a catch but
he was so [ __ ] athletic that despite
the fact that that guy was pulling him
down to the ground he still [ __ ]
caught it the other guy had positioned
he still [ __ ] called it caught it he
was going down to the ground he still
maintained possession of the [ __ ]
ball and then as a presence of mind to
see the goal line and try to get it
across
which is that's what caused the ball not
to be caught
it's because Dez Bryant is so [ __ ]
good I mean that's another thing is the
Cowboys spent all this [ __ ] money on
this guy
a first round draft pick for that exact
moment in the game and the guy delivered
and that stupid rule takes it away
ah
ah [ __ ] unreal Jesus Christ is there
anybody remotely athletic looking who
can actually get on the TV and tell me
why that isn't a [ __ ] catch
put it this way I understand why Howie
Long thought it was a catch and that
[ __ ] nerd who goes out loud you know
you can't count the Stepside you can't
die you know he has a ball pull hands
but there has to be clear and present
danger with a uh a a a motive involved
and and and and you got to take the due
process whatever the [ __ ] he was talking
about as you're watching literally like
he was almost like a cult leader who was
just telling you what you were seeing
wasn't happening so they'll still think
you know his version of Jesus or
whatever
he he caught the [ __ ] ball here's
another thing another rule let's just
talk about NFL rules here
ground can't cause a fumble why
the ground causes a fumble every [ __ ]
game I see it all the time the ground
can't cause a fumble you just don't call
it the ground causes way more fumbles
than Lawrence Taylor ever [ __ ] did
ground can't cause a fumble
that's [ __ ] you should say we don't
count it if the ground causes a fumble
I mean that that's that's how I looked
at that play Dez Bryant caught the ball
and then the ground caused the fumble
and then he [ __ ] recovered it
now not according to rule number
98.75 in the The Book of Genesis what a
crock of [ __ ] that [ __ ] rule is
or is it a good Rule and it just had an
unfortunate time of rearing its ugly
head
I gotta wait a second as all those fat
cheese eating morons are [ __ ] nodding
their jobs right now can you hear it can
you hear them shaking up and running
Rhinelander whatever the [ __ ] I used to
do gigs out there
um
and I didn't have a [ __ ] dog in that
fight I just as an NFL fan was like oh
my God the Cowboys are not gonna get a
touchdown and go up
and I get to see if the Packers can
answer just no no no the Nerds come out
with their [ __ ] protractors do you
understand that they just said you can't
count the steps the guy caught the ball
and is running as he's falling to the
ground
he's still running
because he's that level of an athlete
and they go you can't count that
all right whatever
oh Jesus Christ
Jesus Christ I mean that almost killed
the excitement I had of the patriots
beating the Ravens that's how much I
[ __ ] hate this
the turn that Sports have taken you know
where they got all these [ __ ] causes
attached to everything and people crying
during the [ __ ] commercials and then
this [ __ ] you get to watch a guy make a
[ __ ] great catch and then it's taken
away because of
the last [ __ ] hair of the [ __ ] move
that's what they look at everything else
of that amazing play nah it doesn't
count
doesn't [ __ ] count and there's
another thing too
the amount of [ __ ] morons that don't
understand the definition of karma
who sat there and said that's Karma baby
you know because there was a [ __ ] call
the week before that went in favor of
the Cowboys the Cowboys didn't make the
call
all the Cowboys are guilty of is showing
up and playing the Detroit Lions
if anybody's going to pay for those bad
calls it's still refs
the refs [ __ ] the Lions not the Cowboys
so then the refs come back the next week
and what are they doing are they evening
out their karma
what does that mean so that means I
could go out and go murder somebody and
then the next week I help an old lady
across the [ __ ] Street and then it's
even
it isn't
they [ __ ]
they [ __ ] up two weeks in a goddamn
row
I don't know I I just
I can't [ __ ] believe that's not a
catch the stupidest thing ever
he caught the ball you can't count that
he's still going down to the ground yeah
he's getting tackled
he had to jump over the guy he's getting
tackled and he still maintained control
of the [ __ ] ball and anybody who
tries to say when he reached out with
that ball that that ball isn't right as
rain and is not even moving and that Dez
Bryant does not have completely complete
control of that you're a Packer fan or
you're a [ __ ] you're you're yeah I
don't know what you are
I don't know what you're looking at
though he clearly has like the fact that
the fact that it has to be up against
your [ __ ] body the guy's clearly
reaching towards the goal line I I all
right I'm done I'm done
all right we're gonna go reverse here in
Reverse Direction we'll do the Sunday
games and then the Saturday games
um
the Colts
beat the Broncos
both Paul verzi and uh Jason long had
both called that lawhead even went as
far as to say that if the Colts rushed
for a hundred yards
against the Broncos they were going to
win by two scores so he extra called it
and um
and once again I feel Vindicated
after 10 years way back in the day when
we were winning championships and they
were still saying if you had to build a
team
you know if I had to pick a guy I'd go
with Peyton Manning over Tom Brady
um I'm telling you I don't know what the
[ __ ] it is
I don't know what the [ __ ] it is but you
saw it this weekend
one guy was down by 14 points twice and
still won the game
and the other guy uh you know
you saw what happened okay I'm sick of
that [ __ ] argument
all right I've said it forever if you
want 600 yards
in October you know who you want
if you want to win in January you know
who you want all right
that's it go [ __ ] yourself
okay and hey Colts fans how psyched to
you that he was on the other side of the
ball now
you know
you got Andrew Luck you know I love
about Andrew Luck is I guess you know
you're going to Stanford he was a
three-point something GPA and I guess
he's a super smart guy I love the fact
that he's a super smart guy but he looks
like he should be barefoot wearing
overalls sitting next to a moonshine
still
you know he looks like right out of like
Central Casting like he'd just be
sitting there with some straw hanging
out of his mouth
um
and I think that they're going to give
the Patriots a hell of a [ __ ] game
next week and uh that's once again just
like when we played the Ravens
I wasn't going to be surprised if we
lost at home because uh dude the [ __ ]
Ravens man what an organization they are
you know
losing all those guys Ed Reed Ray Lewis
and Ray Rice and they still come out
they got a beast at running back how
[ __ ] horrific did we look against the
Run letting up that guy that guy must
have averaged like 12 yards per carry in
the first half
um that game was an absolute classic and
I'm not gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] talk or
anything about that because uh
I actually I like the Ravens I think
their organization is I think they're a
great [ __ ] organization and uh
I wish that we had the knack for
drafting drafting defensive players the
way they do or what the whatever the
[ __ ] they're doing down there
um
so I didn't see the Seattle game because
I was flying out uh flying out to New
Orleans but um I did see bits and pieces
of it and I'm sticking with that that's
my pick
to uh to win the Super Bowl
um is going to be the uh the Seattle
Seahawks are going to repeat
unless they completely [ __ ] up
which would be fun to see
you know with all the bandwagon Seahawk
fans now which you always get when we
got the bandwagon [ __ ] Patriots fans
all those jerk offs coming to the
stadium now dressed like [ __ ] Paul
Revere
showing up to the game with your dumb
long rifle whatever the [ __ ] you're
doing dick where were those guys where
were those guys back in the day one of
Sullivan Stadium looked like
some glorified high school program where
the [ __ ] were they they went nowhere so
I'm not [ __ ] them when I [ __ ] on
Seahawk fans I'm not [ __ ] on those
people that [ __ ] sat in the Kingdom
and Seahawk fans you know who the [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] none
that's [ __ ] jerk off showing up
painting themselves green
who does that
with your construction helmet this how
many of those [ __ ] people that wear
those construction helmets are actually
construction people working on a job
site
how shameful would that be
if you actually showed up wearing a
construction helmet and you can't
construct anything
right I would be as offended if you
showed up wearing a [ __ ] apron you
couldn't make a pie crust from scratch
[ __ ] jerk off showing up with your
[ __ ] American flag on the side of
your helmet
oh God turns out you're an accountant
who just does P90X
[Music]
[Laughter]
and who paints you back that's what I
want to know is it your buddy
does he put the green makeup on your
back
the whole [ __ ] thing is just so
Dungeons and Dragons it just gives me
deuce chills I can't handle it so
anyways next week
um
I gotta be honest with you I don't know
who the [ __ ] gonna win
I have no idea man I'm sticking with my
pick that Seattle's gonna repeat and uh
you know and other than that I just got
a bunch of cliches if anything can
happen if anybody can beat the [ __ ]
Seahawks it's the [ __ ] Packers or
whatever but
um
I think it's going to be uh Patriots
Seattle in the Super Bowl
and I I don't know the fact that we got
absolutely no pressure
on Joe Flacco and we were actually
getting manhandled by two rookie linemen
I don't think that
that's a good thing considering they
have uh Wilson and [ __ ]
whatever the [ __ ] his name is there
who ran through the entire Saints
Marshawn Lynch
I don't think that's going to be a good
thing for us
and uh yeah I would say that
I would say that and just but as far as
like the defenses that be played up
against to see how much Brady has been
on his back
um to then go up against Seattle who
looks like they are the best [ __ ]
defense out there like I just I mean
it's not [ __ ] rocket science I mean
obviously as a Patriots fan I hope that
we would beat him but uh I don't know
I don't [ __ ] I don't [ __ ] know
dude you know I am I can't [ __ ] get
over the fact that they took that
[ __ ] catch away
ah Jesus Christ what a [ __ ] buzz kill
weren't weren't well then you just get
to watch them run out the clock
anyways let's get to some of the [ __ ]
advertising here for this week
um why do they make you say it three
times
every [ __ ] one of them
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
that's like yeah I [ __ ] got it
um sorry I'm in such a [ __ ] mood at the
[ __ ] goddamn blue balls I have
watching that [ __ ] package goddamn
[ __ ] game
come on it's a football fan you didn't
want to see the Cowboys score and then
see Aaron Rodgers come down and answer
it
and I go [ __ ] yourselves um anyways
hey what book I talk about this week oh
I I uh as far as the helicopter license
thing goes I sold it for the first time
this week off Airport
uh the first one I did was for as it
goes 45 minute round trip but the second
one I threw I flew for three hours and
six minutes by myself
over the LA Basin and I'm not gonna lie
to you that was the scariest [ __ ]
thing I've ever done in my life
and uh
I told my instructor that too when I
came back I was told them I was scared
shitless and he laughed his ass off and
said that he was too so it actually made
me feel
normal because I got to be honest with
you by the time I got back to the
airport I didn't want to fly anymore I
was looking down at the Hobbs meter and
I had to have three hours by myself or
else this lesson didn't count and I got
there I looked down and I was like uh
24 minutes short like the Hobbs meter
rolls in like six minute intervals so I
was yeah six times four is 24 minutes
short
so I had to fly the [ __ ] traffic
pattern for like 24 minutes before I
finally set the thing down and I'll tell
you my favorite part of the flight was
when I pulled the mixture and the
[ __ ] engine shut off
[Music]
[Laughter]
the scariest [ __ ] thing it was also
awesome
you know what it is it's in between in
between airports is cool making the
radio calls and that even though I [ __ ]
them up
um
it's it's the going when you get to an
airport it's like am I gonna be able to
see it
am I going to get in the traffic pattern
the right way
do I know which way the runways all of
that [ __ ] [ __ ] even though you know
it you're just sitting there going oh my
God what if I [ __ ] this up what if I
[ __ ] this up what if I [ __ ] this up and
it's the biggest [ __ ] relief
when you join the traffic pattern you
get clearance and everything and you did
it right
I did one came in low approach and then
took off which means I don't land and I
was like okay thank God thank God that's
[ __ ] over and then I had to go land
at this other one and uh
I don't know I came back and I was on
the wrong [ __ ] frequency and I'm
calling the [ __ ] airport and then I
you know
they're not hearing what I'm saying and
I'm going and the information I need is
in the UN like in the compartment under
the seat so I'm literally going like now
what the [ __ ] do I do
I gotta fly back to the other airport
get into the airspace that's what I got
to do now I got to ask them what the
[ __ ] frequency is but fortunately the
tower picked it up saw me coming in and
told me what frequency I needed to be on
which was such a [ __ ] relief
and um
dude I gotta tell you I [ __ ] I've
gone skydiving
I did doing stand-up show time at the
Apollo I'm trying to think like
other than you know maybe I don't know
walking into the ocean
I went snorkeling one time in the
[ __ ] Caribbean and that was that was
right up there was nothing as scary as
that just looking over at that [ __ ]
empty seat just going like if anything
[ __ ] up right now this is on me
um
[ __ ] emotionally spent then I went
home and I uh
I'm not gonna lie I had a belt of
whiskey and I felt
I felt a little better but uh then a
couple nights later I had my first night
flight and did that with an instructor
it was the coolest [ __ ] thing I ever
did and I actually got to transition
uh Bravo airspace over [ __ ] uh LAX
at night it was the coolest thing I ever
[ __ ] did
as far as flying as I'm flying
you know your transition I think it was
like at 1500 feet that's literally like
a commercial jet Landing underneath you
looks [ __ ] unreal
it was [ __ ] unreal
I felt like I was in Die Hard
[Laughter]
and um
I'm not gonna lie to you man
flew all the way up to camarilla airport
landed there
and it's just a whole other [ __ ]
world
so I'm flying this little egg beater
right
Robinson R22 look it up yeah I know it
looks [ __ ] small and it is small it's
basically the Smart Car of [ __ ]
helicopters but what I like about it is
because it's so not complex there's way
less less [ __ ] that can possibly fail on
the [ __ ] thing but anyways you land
at these airports and then you just see
you just see this whole other world
of just people you don't run into
because they have their own airplanes
you know
like I don't I don't know what these
people do for a [ __ ] living but my
instructor's going like just pointing
out the planes
that's eight million that's 15 million
that's a G6
Jerry Jones of the Cowboys has one
that's 52 [ __ ] million 52 million
dollars
what are the monthly payments on that
how do you even buy a jet
is it like going in when you get a car
and you go in there and some you know
you're looking at the jet you just walk
up on the lot and then some scumbag
comes walking around the other side hey
you like this one that's a G6 it's got
his hands in his pocket rubbing his
[ __ ] ball back what do we gotta do
today to get you in this jet tomorrow
um I'm sure you don't right
I think when you buy big [ __ ] like that
don't you just call up
you know well I'm seriously red
traveling like one of those plates
then they just [ __ ] you know stock it
up with booze and [ __ ] and they give
it to you with a big bow on it isn't
that what you do
pay for it with your blood diamond money
I don't I don't know what the [ __ ]
happens but um
yeah I'm about a month out I got six
more flights and uh I'm doing all the
pre uh the pre-test right now to finally
go and get my license and uh I can't
[ __ ] wait
I can't [ __ ] wait this is something I
never thought I'd be able to accomplish
because I'm [ __ ] stupid
and uh I knew I'd be able to fly the
goddamn thing but it's I'm the ground
school and all the science and physics
behind it I thought I was gonna [ __ ] up
but I actually I actually really enjoyed
it I was having flashbacks when I was in
high school and I didn't know the
answers and all that [ __ ] I didn't get
stuff but uh fortunately I had really
good instructors so it's been going it's
been going pretty good so far
that's all I can tell you
um
part of that night flight came out of
the valley went right up over Griffith
Park flew between the observatory
and and the [ __ ] Hollywood Sign then
you just follow the roads made a left
down the [ __ ] 101 went right down
downtown L.A and as I come and flying
down
started heading south
I'm seeing this thing it looks like
the top of a smoke stack like what the
[ __ ] is that and it was the the
fireworks over Disneyland
he always killing me
I was saying to my instructor going
that's Disney Disneyland is right
[ __ ] there
like when you drive to Disneyland from
[ __ ] Los Angeles it seems like it's
[ __ ] 400 miles away
and I'm literally sitting in this
helicopter and looking back over my
shoulder to roughly where I live and
then looking over my other shoulder and
I can see where Disneyland is it's like
I could ride a bicycle there
um anyways if I'm gonna boring you with
this [ __ ]
um let's get on to some of the reads
here this week uh
oh by the way
um here's something this is uh this is
not even an advertisement this is a good
thing that you can do uh be the
match.org uh it's a national registry
for donating bone marrow uh they send
you a kit
uh you swap oh my God I thought they
were gonna say you do it yourself just
[ __ ] Jam a needle in there
no they send you a kit you swab your
cheek
and mail it back if you're a match you
can save someone's life they handle all
expenses uh also saving someone's life
is a great story to help you get laid
thanks who the hell wrote that uh tons
of emails
calling you out on the traffic Gap
95 percent of them explain the
importance of safety and efficiency two
examples below oh okay here we go the
traffic Gap
um oh yeah I got a lot of these people
who talk about how they drive a stick
shift
first off I have a stick shift so rather
than driving Bumper to Bumper and riding
my clutch I give myself some room so
that once I see those red brake lights
come on in front of me I let off the gas
and then accelerate again once the brake
light goes off I hardly ever have to
come to a complete stop and shift yeah
it might sound selfish and lazy but
whatever I'm sure it was some selfish
texting jerk off that got in the
accident up the road that caused all of
the traffic to begin with oh yeah there
you go justify how you don't understand
how to drive a stick shift
you know all you got to do you first of
all you're not riding your clutch riding
your clutch is when you have it
partially engaged and disengaged and
you're hitting the gas
that is riding the clutch
all right all you got to do is as you
Coast up just put it in neutral you can
take your foot off
you could do that you could give a [ __ ]
about the person behind you
riding the clutch
um anyways I'm gonna burn out my clutch
man
doing what
engaging it properly
um secondly I don't I guess maybe the
the other components of it but the
clutch itself you're not going to uh
burn out right anyway secondly a lot of
traffic is formed just because people
are merging onto the highway and without
providing some space how the [ __ ] will
the flow start up again please tell me
you're not one of those douches that
doesn't let people merge because you
think you have more important [ __ ] to
get to
uh no but I'm also not one of those
douches that thinks that people changing
lanes causes traffic
okay what causes traffic is there's not
too many [ __ ] people and not enough
lanes for the amount of people on the
highway
I'm sure people cutting in and out
doesn't help
okay
but I changed lanes all the time
when I drive down the road and if
there's no nobody on the road it doesn't
cause traffic
um
yeah that's just some [ __ ] no I let
people on the on the road
I've actually now that I've started
flying I have actually become way more
[ __ ] courteous
a driver but um
and when somebody cuts me off and
actually does a crazy move so I don't
flip out I just go I've done that it's a
good move I can't get mad I can't get
mad at an aggressive move
it's that just
that [ __ ]
just laying back 20 [ __ ] car links
it's just so [ __ ] selfish
just pull up everybody wants to get to
where they're going just inch up as the
traffic is inching up do everybody else
a [ __ ] solid you're not burning out
your clutch
you know you decide you're the one who
decided to get a [ __ ] stick shift did
you think you were never going to run
into traffic so now everybody behind you
have to
dude I got a [ __ ] on my old truck
that thing's a [ __ ] to to shift
I don't even have
power steering on that goddamn thing I
come home I'm an old man I'm tired when
I drive it but I still pull up you lazy
[ __ ] anyway secondly a lot of traffic
storm just because
oh no I actually read that okay number
two
8 billion on the uh on this last week's
show you worked yourself up into a
normal your normal frenzy just thinking
about dudes who leave space in front of
them in traffic and couldn't fathom any
reason why someone could do this the
fact that you use the word fathom I'm
expecting I'm accepting uh expecting
that you're going to be doing something
you're going to really talk down to me
here
um I'm one of those guys though maybe
not exactly what you were describing
that leaves space in front of my car in
traffic uh there there is a simple
reason why fluid dynamics
a few years ago I stumbled upon this
website
trafficwaves.org and it changed my whole
way of thinking about traffic I'm not a
scientist so I can't do as good a job
explaining traffic is this guy but
essentially traffic jams can be thought
of as traveling waves of condensation
and a single driver can disrupt these
Waves by anticipating jams and
maintaining a constant rate of travel
rather than engaging in stop and go
traffic
uh and go with the flow of stuff traffic
a single driver has the effect of
disrupting the traffic wave for the
vehicles behind that drive yeah I've
done that I've slowed how quickly I've
come up but I'm talking about leaving
like I know exactly what you're talking
about I actually experimented one time
if I could drive
slow like because you'll see like
traffic moving up and stopping
so and then you see the Ripple of
movement coming towards you
and then as that Ripple movement's
coming towards you you see where it
stops starts to move again and then you
experiment can I keep
keep everybody behind me to continue
moving
without having to step on the brake I've
done that but you don't have to do that
from [ __ ] 50 [ __ ] car links behind
you because when you do that everybody
starts cutting into your lane
anyways I'll continue with what he's
saying in other words
if I drive at a constant rate of speed
approaching and through a traffic jam so
will other Drives By drivers behind me
and the jam itself will disappear
um no it doesn't
it doesn't disappear there's still a
zillion cars in front of you and you're
going half a mile an hour
so rather than going 18 miles an hour
and then stopping
and then going 18 miles an hour and
stopping you're just going to
consistently go half a mile a [ __ ] an
hour and then mathematically you feel
like you're going faster
anyway so besides saving me the mental
stress of stop and go traffic I drive a
stick so it's especially annoying and
save the wear on my car I'm also
improving the driving conditions for my
fellow commuters now Jesus this guy's
making himself into being a hero
something to think about the next time
you're screaming at the slow guy in
front of you I knew it
the second he said fathom I knew there
was going to be some sort of life lesson
in there
um I you guys are fooling yourself
okay you're eliminating the Stop and Go
part of the traffic but you're not
eliminating the traffic and you're
completely ignoring the fact that
there's way too [ __ ] many people on
the road for the amount of [ __ ] Lanes
there's still traffic
all right
with your little Ripple theater uh
Theory there I don't buy into it
um other than the fact that you can keep
it
going at a ridiculously low rate of
speed
um I think it's common sense that
somebody then cutting into your lane
because they then take up that space
that that will cause you to stop but
this this fantasy that if everybody just
stayed in their lanes and coasted along
that you wouldn't be late now and that
there would be no traffic
I guess there would be no stop in the
truck they would still be [ __ ]
traffic
all right
there you go okay devastated hi Bill
I'm from the UK and I've recently
discovered your brand of Comedy wait
let's go back to the traffic thing
okay
so how about everybody who's listening
to this stuff
all right how about you try to keep it
moving by doing that type of thing while
you also agree that you're still in a
traffic jam
can we all do that there's a little bit
of both everybody happy
devastated oh and everybody who buys a
stick shift know that you're going to be
in traffic someday and that it's going
to suck and don't make the person behind
you have to [ __ ] pay for your uh
you know
your [ __ ] decision to get a standard
rather than an automatic all right
devastated hi Bill I'm from the UK and
I've recently discovered your brand of
Comedy which is fantastic well thank you
my brother who lives in Pittsburgh was
over in the UK in December and I was
showing him your stand up on Netflix and
he's now spreading the joy however
imagine
to our horror when our 64 year old mom
decides to tell us that she really
fancies the ginger guy
you were just watching
um
what I was just watching
your word he actually wrote your words
you mean you were watching my dad is a
ginger so I suppose it's
understandable not understandable
understandable uh keep up the good work
love to see you in the UK sometime and
go [ __ ] yourself
uh
wait a minute I don't understand the
whole what the [ __ ] was that whole thing
you enjoy me
oh fancies as in likes me thinks I'm a
good looking guy oh that's hilarious
that's right buddy deal with it deal
with the image of your mother riding me
it's disgusting I'm sorry
Jesus Christ dude you know if you worked
on your pronouns and your spelling I
could have got that all in one take all
right extra point Billy botch snap Burr
uh my brother and I were kickers back in
the back in our day he played D1 college
football I wasn't that good but still
better than most kickers in high school
at the time anyways I wanted to defend
the extra point just like you do it
isn't the most difficult thing to do but
it's super but it's super important I've
missed an extra point when time was
expired which resulted in a one-point
loss for our team Jesus Christ let me
tell you that weighs on a person heavily
as a kicker you have all the eyes on you
making a mistake
um that much more making a mistake that
much more noticeable true story while in
college my brother missed an important
kick and received death threats for one
kick quarterbacks and running backs can
often be balled out bikes bailed out by
excuses
um such as the line didn't block well or
whatever the extra point looks so easy
because football fans are having the
opportunity to watch someone who takes
time and puts effort into the craft of
kicking watch a high school game or a
college game where there's not a true
not a true kicker at the position and
I'm sure 99.9 or whatever
don't get made
um I wouldn't say it's that high I can
make an extra point but I still like the
extra point I am biased I guess but [ __ ]
it kicking is hard and unappreciated in
my eye underappreciated in my eyes
thanks for the last and go [ __ ] yourself
um yeah absolutely
yeah listen first he actually went 4-0
this weekend
um with his his
um
playoff picks and if you don't believe
him listen to him gloat about it for an
hour on his podcast dude what did I say
I'm [ __ ] amazing
um
but uh you know
I don't know I'm one of those guys I
like that I like that nerdy [ __ ]
I'm so [ __ ] sick of not being able to
yell this week Jesus [ __ ] Christ
um anyways
what am I doing here Clan problems
oh Jesus Christ
how [ __ ] creepy is it by the way that
horrific thing that happened in uh
in France and now watching all these
[ __ ] people coming out there and
trying to blame the goddamn religion
over it
like we don't have Jesus Freaks that
blow up abortion clinics
[ __ ] and just [ __ ] drives me nuts
that adults can [ __ ] think that way
you know what I mean
good [ __ ] I mean you could basically you
could attach
any bad thing that happens all you have
to do is just
find out what religion the person is and
then everybody in that thing is is
[ __ ]
is [ __ ] wrong
then they just they're [ __ ]
everywhere they're under your bed and
then they try to get everybody into this
giant panic
I don't [ __ ] get it it's like
but like the whole [ __ ] Isis thing
you're literally talking about they
don't have a Navy they don't have any
[ __ ] air support
granted they could come over here and
they could do something horrific yes but
the level of what they could do versus
what the [ __ ] we can do
I'm just not going to get into this
panic and I live
you know I live in Los Angeles and I go
to LAX all the [ __ ] time God knows
what the [ __ ] could happen
all right but to sit there and listen to
these [ __ ] jerk offs on TV try to get
me into this fearful state
that you know we have to you know
just obliterate an entire [ __ ]
religion
and just watching adults just give in to
that it's just it's the most it's the
dumbest [ __ ] thing I've ever seen in
my life
it's no different than like when that uh
Ebola thing and everybody was freaking
out because like 12 people had it oh my
God
what's gonna happen what's gonna happen
is we're gonna deal with it and
everybody's gonna be [ __ ] fine
all right
the [ __ ] that they say on TV is going to
get a lot of innocent people you know
something [ __ ] horrible is going to
happen to them so that that's your
[ __ ] response
you know
innocent people die so then more
innocent people have to die it's just I
don't know although [ __ ] thing's
depressing and with that let's talk
about Clan problems uh I live in rural
Alabama and have a problem only someone
in my Savage ass backwards inbred area
of the country could have I'm a 25 year
old female and my dad my dad is a member
of the local organization of the KKK
um but by the way it's it's the coup
Klux Klan not the clue
cool
all right
like yin and yang it's not ying and yang
as I said forever I also said the Klu
Klux Klan
um
anyways he's he's a he's a member of the
local organization of the Ku Klux Klan I
actually just for comedic reasons would
love to go to a clan meeting
just to listen to what they say and then
I would just start talking and see how
much [ __ ] I could make up
just to hear him I know I know it I was
thinking that the other day
um a full racist slurs spewing white
supremacist that's what a dad is I have
a six-year-old daughter that I have
that I had after a one night stand so
the child is half Mexican half white gee
I wonder how that happened
they've rebelled against your death look
at that you attract what you fear uh my
dad her grandfather treats her terribly
not
not with like physical abuse or anything
but horror horrible name-calling
taunting
in quotes go back to Mexico you wet back
he says that to a six-year-old to a
[ __ ] she wrote to a [ __ ]
six-year-old girl
I like to go back to Mexico when the kid
was born here
hahaha
uh even though she doesn't really
understand what they are saying to her
it tears me up inside every time I take
her to a gathering with them and subject
her to this treatment I really wish I
could just disown him that was going to
be my suggestion move to another part of
America that is actually civilized
and wouldn't care about this but I can't
pull myself away from the fact that it
is my father and we're supposed to love
each other especially with the
family-centered society we have uh here
in the south
uh but I feel like I'm being very
selfish subjecting my daughter to this
horrible abuse because I'm too weak to
leave uh what what do you think I should
do uh first of all you should stop being
so hard on yourself
you can't pick who your parents are
and uh you know you're not being weak
because that is your dad and you're
gonna love him
I think you're actually uh a
well-adjusted person do you understand
what you're doing to your daughter and I
think you know the decision you're going
to have to make
and um
I don't know I guess to make yourself
feel better I would try to
give this guy another chance before he
goes off to his clan meeting you know
when he's got the sheet on but not the
hood right as he's putting it on just
like hey Dad can I talk to you for a
second and he just lifts up the sheet
like what what's that
what do you want to talk about and just
give him a chance just say listen I'm
going to leave if you don't stop
ah [ __ ] that he's not gonna stop
you gotta leave
you should just leave and then Skype
with them
you know
would that be the thing to do what a
[ __ ] horrible uh
I can't believe that there's still the
clan
you know what I mean that this this
[ __ ]
that's gotta seem so so surreal to be
that that's like uh
being in the clan it's like wearing a
powdered wig you know it's like you
still doing that
you know they got hair plugs
um
anyways I'll let you know something up
that actually depresses the [ __ ] out of
me I'm sorry that you're going through
that but I got to be honest with you uh
the South gets a bad rap as far as
people thinking that that's the only
place that there's morons to think
horrible [ __ ] things
uh
look at some of the [ __ ] that was said
about Muslims the Muslim religion
anyways after what happened in France
by people who weren't in the South these
are people who actually were journalists
um went to college and all of that type
of [ __ ] so uh
I don't know
I don't [ __ ] know but I would tell
you it's I I wouldn't do that to a kid
if your parents were saying some stuff
like that
Ah that's just really not funny is it
all right let's [ __ ] read uh let's
read some advertising here for this week
um
where the [ __ ] is it the live reads
now why won't that pop up
I'm literally looking for the live reads
and all I have right now is just a uh
there it is
some reason it was somebody drew the sun
and it was smiling at me
all right stamps.com everybody one great
resolution you can make for the new year
maximize every minute and every dollar
for your small business I know an easy
way to do that with stamps.com think
about how much time you're wasting going
to the post office driving there
finding parking
talking to the homeless guy holding the
door dude I'll get you on the way out
right stamps.com is the better way to
get postage just use what you already
have your computer and printer
to get official US postage for any
letter or packages or package sorry and
then
then the mailman picks it up with
stamps.com everything you do with the
post office you can do right at home
from your own goddamn desk and at a
fraction of the cost of one of those
expensive postage meters I've been using
stamps.com for the last couple of years
sending out all my posters if ever any
time I'm going to sell something I'll
send it out
um via uh stamps.com
right now use my last name Burr Burr to
get this special offer Norris trial plus
110 bonus offer includes a digital scale
and up to 55 free postage don't wait go
to stamps.com before you do anything
else click on the microphone at the top
of the home page and type in Burr uh
Burr that stamps.com enter Burr
oh dude you know what else I heard when
I was I was doing that flight
that solo flight as uh uh oh no the day
before before and I did it with the
instructor we were flying by this
airport where they have people uh
you know I take people up to go
skydiving and immediately of course the
night before I'm actually thinking like
what if somebody's shoot doesn't open
and that guy lands in my [ __ ] main
rotor
then what do I do
I plummet to my death that's what I do
um so anyways we were coming up on that
airport
and we hear this guy come on the radio
and he's talking to the people down on
the ground he goes
he goes all right he goes that's the
second time he goes that Korean guy
jumped out of the airplane in full power
because he's gonna rip my tail off
some [ __ ] maniac
I guess it was his second time he's gone
up there skydiving you're supposed to
wait till the plane slows down so you
fall away from the plane rather than go
directly back into this [ __ ] Maniac
jumped out at full power
um
and the combination of the anger and
fear in this guy's voice because he
almost just [ __ ] died because this
jerk off jumped out
uh was hilarious to me
um anyways anyways whatever the [ __ ] you
gonna do you know what's another scary
thing too is when somebody announces
their position
and you're saying like you know I'm
flying along the tent at 1500 feet
westbound
facing traffic or whatever and then you
hear somebody else announce that they're
in your same area
headed Eastbound and they're roughly the
same at altitude and immediately what I
do is I either climb or go down a couple
hundred [ __ ] feet
and you're just like [ __ ] where is he
where are there he is there he is
thank Christ anyways I'm speaking to
watch another great comic past
um the other day Taylor Negron everybody
uh
I only
met him one time and met him down at the
Improv on Melrose and um
I told him how much I loved his area rug
joke you guys ever see the movie
punchline
and he was talking about going in to buy
a carpet and there was the uh the
Immigrant guy in there and I don't know
what the [ __ ] he was but he was talking
about how when he said area rug
he said he did he just opened his mouth
and he didn't form any syllable I'm
butchering the joke
and he goes uh yeah hey you know I want
a uh
I want I need to buy a carpet not a big
thing just sort of a small you know
little sectional thing a little carpet
kind of thing and the guy goes you don't
want to cop it you want an eye on
area rug whatever you got to see him do
it his [ __ ] tongue's literally doing
the wave he played within um
it was a pizza guy Fast Times at
Ridgemont High
um
he was in uh was it fast money something
like that the [ __ ] was it the Ronnie
Dangerfield one whatever just an
absolutely brilliant guy a true [ __ ]
artist unfortunately passed away at
cancer at 57 so uh shout out to him
Taylor Negron uh go on YouTube watch his
videos watch his movies tell people
about him
um just an amazing amazing artist and
Eddie Brill by the way on Facebook was
really good friends with them and uh
wrote away more better tribute than I
just tried to give him so anyways
let's go back here let's go back here to
the [ __ ]
dude this podcast sounds like you
remember that SNL sketch that Alec
Baldwin did when they made fun of uh
what is it NPR
they talked about sweaty balls that's
been my tone this entire [ __ ] podcast
I'll make it up next week when I can
actually scream and yell here why the
[ __ ] do I get the sunny smiley face
again why does it keep doing that
um
by the way guys I really got to work on
my [ __ ] temper
I really do
I get into a [ __ ] argument with my
wife right
and she [ __ ] wrote me
I've never seen this before it was like
a text message that was as long as the
Gettysburg Address
about all the things that I was doing
wrong
okay reams of information about what I
was doing wrong and I gotta be honest
with you I couldn't argue with any of it
hahaha
if anybody
knows a way that I can stop flipping out
over little things and no this isn't
going to hurt my [ __ ] act because
I'll still have the thought and I'll be
able to go off in a comedic way
on stage if anybody knows a good way to
do it
I sat there and I thought about all the
[ __ ]
dumb things that made me flip out
yesterday
when I sat down and I was watching uh
I was watching 60 minutes
and they were showing wounded Veterans
of the Iraqi War this one guy like lost
both his legs below the knee lost the
thumb a chunk of his [ __ ] left arm
and his left eye
and he's being positive and he's [ __ ]
you know going up this hill like Jerry
Rice would run up and I'm sitting here
flipping out because [ __ ] people
leave too much space
in traffic
I swear to God man like
I don't I don't know I don't know how to
beat it
I got I have the shortest remember those
[ __ ] what color were the firecrackers
was it the black ones that had the
really short Wick that you literally had
to be throwing them as you were lighting
them like that is my temper
like I have such a bad [ __ ] temper at
this point like now when I drive in the
car I let my wife Drive
like some guy who's got his [ __ ]
balls in her purse I just do it to keep
the peace because if I'm riding in the
car
I I don't flip out as much as when I'm
driving
and I just I don't know you realize how
ridiculous it is that I'm an angry man
and a Prius
how dumb is that
and the sound of my horn as I'm
screaming and yelling at people how
[ __ ] ridiculous I look and the fact
that I know I looked that ridiculous and
I still can't stop doing it like it is a
real
it's a real [ __ ] problem
I don't know this I can't tell if I
learned it from the people around me or
if you're just born an angry [ __ ]
maniac
but uh it's a battle I've been fighting
for the last 15 years
of my adult life and I am
I don't think I've moved an inch forward
other than just being able to admit I
have a [ __ ] major goddamn problem
with my temper
like do you realize how [ __ ] mad I
got yesterday with that Dez Bryant catch
I had talked about it for the first 20
minutes of the podcast
who gives a [ __ ] bill
it's not your team you don't have any
money on the game
why do I give a [ __ ] why does it then
anger me when the guy comes on the TV to
explain it and I'm immediately looking
going this guy sucked in gym class
you [ __ ] suck [ __ ] and I'm yelling at
the TV [ __ ] you you can't even catch a
football you [ __ ] [ __ ] just
maniac
I'm in a [ __ ] hotel room and yeah I
know the people on the other side of the
wall can hear me
how long am I gonna continue to [ __ ]
embarrass myself
like you know what my wife can't even
watch [ __ ] TV with me
because I won't shut the [ __ ] up and
something bugs me every three seconds
and I and I start yelling at the TV like
it's a person in the room
I swear to God
I swear to God I I should have bought a
house with a room over the garage and I
should be like sent there
you know
like an inmate and every once in a while
you let me out you walk me around the
front yard until I start getting heated
about some dumb [ __ ] you know
that somebody came by with a doggy poop
bag and put it in my recycled trash can
it doesn't [ __ ] go with the blue one
goes in the black one just a [ __ ] it's
embarrassing anyways uh bill can I
bounce back from Bad first time at sex
absolutely you're not supposed to be
good the first time
you're supposed to be so freaked out
that you're doing it that you you
the game's over before it even starts
right
hello Mr Burr huge fan from Poland
um not a virgin by the way here's the
story
I've been hanging out with this girl for
about a year as friends
well right now dude the fact that if you
actually bang this person after being
friends for a [ __ ] year
you know
I mean that's how did you even maintain
an erection with all those memories of
walking around a farmer's market
anyways finally I ended up falling for
her but she put me in the friend zone
well I wasn't having that so I sort of
Pumped the brakes on the whole thing and
stopped hanging out with a textbook
textbook nice move
just some messages from time to time a
few weeks ago she calls me up randomly
to chill at my place after not seeing
each other for a couple of months I was
kind of buzzed so I thought what the
hell why not so she comes over we have
some alcohol maybe some illegal
substances and everything was cool
suddenly she just goes [ __ ] me
Jesus Christ I gotta get over to Poland
so I lifted up her skirt ripped off her
panties Jesus buddy this guy's going
Blow by blow and started plowing her
unfortunately I got the whiskey dick
soon after
[ __ ] my life it was pathetic I ended up
oh Jesus okay he performed oral I gotta
tone this down here
performed oral sex on her she she uh got
where she needed to be
but this was not
the the railing she was probably hoping
for I wanted to kill myself and still do
we still talk but I'm not sure if we'll
ever get a chance to get into her uh
pants again please comfort me Mr Burr
and tell me that it's going to be okay
also exclusion excuse my English it's
not my first language well you spoke
Meathead English perfectly
um
listen dude who's kidnapped the way you
talk about this woman getting her
panties flower [ __ ] and all that you
don't you don't love this woman
you just want someone you can [ __ ] so
whatever you know it didn't work out
move on to somebody else
I think you're gonna be fine
um you did make up for your mistake with
a very courteous move afterwards I don't
think she'd be that upset
um
listen she's probably sitting at home
going did I say [ __ ] me to that guy
did I really just say that oh God and
then his dick went down was he not
turned on by me she's probably doing all
of that [ __ ]
I don't know the more I talk about this
I think you guys Both Deserve Each Other
maybe maybe get back in there
whiskey dick you gotta look you gotta
you know you get whiskey dick you gotta
get yourself in the uh the same mindset
of a relief pitcher that just gave up
with the [ __ ]
the Deep ball
you know but you still up a run
you just got to forget about that just
like Roger Clemens did you know he would
just immediately just you know start
asking for another ball
does that make any [ __ ] sense
actually when I was thinking about that
night I used Roger Clemens as an example
all of a sudden I had a
different vibe to it
um anyways sorry about that oh Jesus
Christ this [ __ ] podcast was an
absolute [ __ ] show well this this ends
the whispering podcast
from a hotel room somewhere in New
Orleans
for the week of uh what the [ __ ] week is
it here
oh Monday January 12th I want to make
sure I got that right because last week
like an [ __ ] I said June uh
June 5th I'm [ __ ] all right anyways
that's a podcast for this week uh I
promise you I will make up for all the
yelling I didn't do this week on next
week's podcast thank you for listening
um anything I got a plug nothing I got
nothing to plug other than I'm going to
be going to Australia New Zealand
Singapore Hong Kong and Mumbai
that's definitely going down and also
the southern bus tour in May
is definitely happening I'm talking to
my agent today he's going to give me all
the dates I've already heard some of the
areas that I'm going to be going to
Sharif Port Louisiana I think is in
there Savannah Georgia
um I think I'm going to be going back to
Charleston North Carolina I mean South
Carolina it's it's going to be
it's going to be insane
and um
as far as I know I think we're we start
in Kentucky and we end in New Orleans
and we're going to all these off off the
beaten path kind of things you know not
the major cities that I've already
played Nashville Atlanta I've already
done those ones so
it's gonna be [ __ ] awesome and also
the weakest shows at the Wilbur Theater
in Boston I'm doing an entire week
Monday through Sunday
shows at the Wilbur Theater uh they've
been selling great
um and I think we're going to start
adding some shows
and um I think that that's something I'm
going to do every other year I think
I'll just do a week of shows in my
hometown
eat all that [ __ ] Chinese food and
all the [ __ ] that I missed Kelly's Roast
Beef [ __ ] slices of pizza and all
that type of all that [ __ ] food that
I used to eat when I was 22 that I
shouldn't be eating now
um
but whatever all right predictions next
week Patriots eek out of Victory
against the Colts and then I think
Seattle
um we'll have a tough game against the
Packers I think they're both going to be
great games
Seattle wins
and then for some dumb reason when we go
to the Super Bowl the Patriots might
actually be even or favored and that's
only because of morons in Vegas who just
can't lay off of Brady and Belichick so
that's really Vegas just trying to get
money on both sides of the ball
it really has nothing to do with the
fact and then I think that we will be
um I wouldn't say manhandled by Seattle
but we will be handled
um
because I just think I it kills me to
say that as a Patriots fan but I'm just
I'm being totally I'm being [ __ ]
brutally honest about football this week
the Tuck Rule is [ __ ] stupid and I
think Seattle's gonna win the goddamn
Super Bowl I hope that we win it
if anybody could figure out how to beat
those guys it will be uh Belichick's
game plan it's just I uh
I don't know I just don't know what
their defense and the fact that we can't
get any [ __ ] pressure on a
quarterback I don't know how the [ __ ]
you're gonna beat Seattle doing that and
the fact that Wilson can run like a
[ __ ] too
that's going to be a nightmare
um so anyways that's my goddamn
prediction
what's up everybody and welcome back to
the anything better podcast NFL Edition
for uh bet MGM guys we're finished it's
a sad thing it's a sad thing to know
that I'm finished I went oh it's five I
went oh and five but before we talk
about the debacle that was my gambling
this year Paul verzi for the second year
in a row beats the book against the
spread picking four games a week not
only beat him this year dare I say put
him across his knee
slapping that ass well if you were 41
what
41 30 what was it 40 31 and one Andrew
yeah
31 and one
nine and a half above 500 against the
spread who does that Paul and there was
a lot of people
a lot of people saying Paul lost his
[ __ ] he lost his uh he doesn't have
it the sophomore slump is what they were
calling in October oh yeah when I was
eight games under they were all going
not this year buddy not this year you
you did you had a 17 game turn around
yeah dude well you know what that's so
did I in the wrong direction
um
yeah man well listen we had a great time
doing it uh we love picking the games
and um we do it with the best uh the
best lines out there guys it's bet MGM
we love working with Ben MGM uh oh you
beat him so bad we were almost combined
at 500.
I want to shout out bed MGM because bet
MGM tweeted bet MGM tweeted today back
to back to me the BET MGM people are
taking [ __ ] notice okay they're gonna
do that's like when Sherman had to go up
and Shake [ __ ] Tom Brady's hand
but MGM was all in your grill you mad
bro you mad hey bet MGM don't try tying
my hands behind my back next year don't
throw some rules in all right
Hey listen you know we went with the
Will Chamberlain rules you still beat
him that's fun that's amazing
um no I was it was a lot of fun guys and
you guys can bet all playoff long all
year long with the best uh live lines
out there bet MGM all you have to do you
know it if you listen to the show as you
download the BET MGM app okay and uh you
use our bonus code which is Burr b-u-r-r
very simple very easy and all you got to
do is put a minimum of ten dollars in
and they will match up to a thousand
dollars even if you lose guys so there
you go
um you put a thousand in
put something on it let it fly they'll
match it all right uh and you could put
as little as ten dollars in so just use
bonus code Burr Burr and you can um you
can uh benefit from that uh promotion so
there you go man bet MGM is the best and
um we got a lot of games this weekend oh
we've got two tomorrow Paul
listen I love I love this I love these
playoffs because there's a couple of
there's a couple of guns in my head
forget gun to my head gun to my mouth I
like some of these
all right on Saturdays the Seattle
Seahawks with Sneaky Pete oof
in Marlin Briscoe uh against the San
Francisco 49ers
in San Francisco
minus nine and a half
see early game it's January it's the
playoffs
what do you what do you like Paul I have
to defer to you all roads we call
version nine and a half is a lot of
points to give to give a team in the
playoffs
uh you know I don't know man that's it
didn't they just play each other too
this is not a game this is not a game
that if we were in our regular season I
would pick I wouldn't pick this game
um I like San Francisco's defensive line
uh let's be honest dude they are playing
with the third string quarterback I know
he's won five in a row and I know he
looks great and he's got a lot of
blocking I get that but nine and a half
points in a playoff game and a division
rival and the experience of Pete Carroll
I'm not touching it I don't like the
points I think the 49ers win the game
but I would take if I had to if I had to
let money fly I might take the Seahawks
all right I take the 49ers
you're taking 49ers to to cover they're
just kicking the [ __ ] out of everybody
and I don't know anything about football
anymore because I can't I don't even
have time to watch it so I mean this is
what's great Paul people they've seen
our records okay I don't want to hear
anybody bitching
that they took that what the [ __ ] I
picked
after the debacle that I've had over the
last six weeks all right you know what
you're getting with me you know what
you're getting with Paul all right next
game on Saturday it's a double header
people uh Los Angeles Chargers are going
to Jacksonville Paul named after Andrew
Jackson
um
the greatest cocktail party what do they
call it in in the world Jacksonville
versus uh sorry Georgia versus Florida
the Jacksonville Jaguars with the good
looking zombie
Trevor uh what's his name there is that
what they call it that's what I call him
he's like a [ __ ] zombie
like I've ever seen when he's talking it
still looks like a picture
ah
uh what's the line on that game
minus two and a half the charges are I
love that I mean Paul that's that's your
team we all know Paul you know come on
Justin Herbert's your guy
I love Herbert I love them I love the
Chargers to win that game they should
win the game they have more weapons more
experience yes they should
but they are the San Diego Chargers and
it's the playoffs and I don't know I
don't know if they built their Stadium
on our old [ __ ] Indian burial ground
some Poltergeist [ __ ]
this game scares me dude
I think I like the Jacks I'm gonna take
the jacks
all right I'm gonna take the Chargers on
this one opposite World here Paul
um Sunday Paul the day of the Lord
yes you go down and you get your next uh
the next
the next Mafia done in your in your
family to get to get baptized on Sunday
after that
you could you got four games Paul
wait tell me there's not going to be
arguments with the wife on this day
right unless you married one of those
[ __ ] that ties off the jersey and goes
to the game you know if you're married a
regular woman she's gonna get [ __ ]
upset all right Miami Dolphins it's the
first game out of the shoot Paul on the
East Coast where Paul loves to dip his
toes in the Sand Miami Dolphins versus
the Buffalo Bills the bills laying 13
and a half
down a cornerback down a cornerback but
doing doing the hot chick hard and doing
the two and all of that they got that
going on
like a like a like a talk show
feel like a daytime talk show somewhere
between the view and Ellen DeGeneres
that's their Vibe right now
yeah wow the [ __ ] Wing eating animals
sacrifice their hips and their shoulders
on those card tables that were meant for
bridge
who do you like here Paul the Dolphins
don't have a quarterback yeah I I got I
think Buffalo just runs all over him
dude I mean not to mention Miami lost
their last
full they they beat the Jets in the last
game nine to six I was like you don't
think Kroll has a game plan for for my
Buffalo Bills I'm coaching the bills
Nick Kroll has the Dolphins I don't I
don't I think that the Buffalo Bills are
gonna [ __ ] run wild all over them I
know that that sounded like a wrestling
promo Hulk Hogan and I loved it because
I agree with you they're gonna kill him
Josh Allen's on that Steamroller and
they're all [ __ ] jumping on top of it
like one of those [ __ ] taxis in
Southeast Asia all right
the next game
the G-Man the New York football Giants
versus the Minnesota Vikings in
Minnesota one of my favorite cities
I have to tell you how much I love
Minnesota
oh who's Paul gonna go with the Vikings
Paul laying
laying three three
um three to the G-men are we what are we
doing here Paul what are we doing here I
gotta take
I gotta go with my Giants getting three
points saquon Barkley's first playoff
game as a giant I know he's gonna be
hyped up Daniel Jones had a great season
we haven't been making too many mistakes
and but here's the real reason why I
like the Giants we were there two weeks
ago and we went to overtime with them we
went to overtime with them and we we
lost by by a long field going over time
the guy hit a 60-something yarder love
it I I think we go in there and beat him
I you know what I love that the Vikings
won the last time
that even increases my odds and even
though you guys don't have Eli Manning
you still got that thing you are the New
York football Giants I'm taking you guys
and they are the Vikings
okay until they [ __ ] ever do
something in the playoffs I'm voting for
I'm rooting for the I'm not I'm I'm
betting on the Giants all right next up
ah
there's another one the Cincinnati
Bengals I bet this game last week first
of all Baltimore Ravens
the Cincinnati Bengals Paul
laying nine I love when you do that it's
my favorite
they're laying nine Paul
the Cincinnati Bengals are laying
they're handing out points in Cincinnati
you take three you get two
Nola Lamar Jackson
was in the Lamar Jackson last week yes
I'm a [ __ ] idiot no wonder I went oh
and five I didn't know that
all right I'm taking Joe Pearl you gotta
take Joey B Joey burrow in that but the
guy smokes sticks
he says sweating [ __ ] he's going to go
out there he's going to beat the [ __ ]
out of him again all right and then for
the the Monday night game
Monday okay so there's not four games on
Sunday my fault only three saving your
marriage here Paul oh this is an
interesting one
the Dallas Cowboys oh versus the Tampa
Bay Buccaneers going into Tommy's House
North a clear water
where Scientology was invented the
Dallas Cowboys
the heroes of the NFL the ones who wear
the white hat what are they doing Paul
they're laying
two and a half
against the stripping capital of the
world
Tampa Bay Florida I'm gonna known as
Tampa it's Tampa Florida
I'm gonna defer to you I'm gonna defer
to you on this one at the beginning I
want to see what your your take is on
this in what [ __ ] world do you give
Tom Brady points at home in the playoffs
the Dallas Cowboys they live off their
[ __ ] history they haven't done [ __ ]
since Jimmy Johnson walked out that door
although what's his face one with
Jimmy's team off the Herschel Walker
trade
all right the guy from Oklahoma whose
Name Escapes Me Right Now Switzer Barry
Switzer Barry Switzer they're [ __ ]
prop Tony Romo you'll hear Tony Romo
[ __ ] announce the game the guy knows
what's gonna happen before it even
[ __ ] happens maybe you should he
shouldn't have had 10 quarterback
coaches in [ __ ] nine seasons
yep it's not a well-run franchise
he's got a big stupid TV that's already
out of date
their entire [ __ ] Stadium now looks
like an old Best Buy to me you know like
a giant Radio Shack that's about to go
out of business they're going into Tampa
Tampa's got [ __ ] they got a boat out
in the end zone for him to party on and
they got Tom Terrific
coming out there
showing them why he's the greatest that
ever did it Paul I take Tom Brady
getting
they're giving him
you don't give Tom Brady points in
January you just don't do it Paul
dude this is so tough because the
Cowboys have a really good team but um
you know yeah I just think until
you Dethrone him as the like no it's Tom
Brady dude it's Tom Brady he's gonna
throw to Mike Evans the defense is going
to be ready to go he had a tough year I
think they're gonna I think they're
gonna beat him I got I got the uh I got
the Bucks
so I have so I have
I have the Bucks the Giants
Andrew you could write this down I have
the Bucks the Giants I have the Chargers
and I have the bills and you have the
49ers and I have the four no you have
the Seahawks I have the Seahawks with
the points with the points all right I
got the 49ers they got the Jags I got
the bills I got the G-Man I got the
Bengals and I got Tommy terrific Tommy
12th who's not going to retire until he
wins 12 [ __ ] Super Bowls and he's
more than halfway there
I got Tom Terrific now let me ask you a
question real quick out of all of those
games
all of those games which one would you
say is your you definitely think like
your your bills okay Buffalo Bills
Steamroller
I I think yeah maybe Bengals Paul I
don't know anything about I think the
Chargers I think the Chargers dude I
think the Chargers are gonna go in there
dude if I'm wrong about this then when
the zombie takes the field Paul he'd
like to feel feelings dude that's one of
the greatest nicknames the good looking
zombie is like that's so incredible
that's incredible the gorgeous zombie
the gorgeous zombie is that's a
wrestling name dude that's like Parts
Unknown dude the gorgeous zombie is like
insane dude and he does look like that
he looks like an undead I'm gonna tell
you this right now I am sick of Patrick
Mahomes and those stupid forward
laterals that aren't forward laterals
anymore take a [ __ ] sack like a
goddamn man of throw it away if he
doesn't know one of those ew and then
they just like oh my God they just say
one like that yeah another if I see
another three yard no look pass to a
wide open receiver
and they act like Magic Johnson
didn't know look past through [ __ ]
trees Paul all right
yeah I know it annoys me and I don't
think they're gonna win I don't think
they're gonna win the AFC I also don't
like that Patrick Holmes runs the way
figure skaters skate when they try to
it's just something about them I've
never seen a guy who plays in the
National Football League walk with his
knees hitting each other every time you
every time he walks yeah he he runs like
Bambi I don't know it's weird he is it
is um all right they want us to do
here's what we're gonna do for bed MGM
everybody we're gonna do a one game
parlay with my New York football Giants
and the Vikings so Bill we get to choose
we get to make a little parlay here a
one game how the [ __ ] do you do a
one-game parlay I gotta bet a bunch of
[ __ ] this is the Monday night special
basically we take the Giants with the
points because we both like the Giants
so that's minus what the Giants are are
laying two and a oh no the Giants are
getting three the Vikings are laying
three points okay so we love the Giants
getting three so that's one
what's number two what do you want
Barclay gets a touchdown I love it I
love that because he's getting one and I
also think saquon Barkley north of 80
yards
oh can we do that Andrew I like that
because saquan's gonna go off in his
first playoff game can we do that
okay
all right I don't like how easy you
agreed with all of that Paul I went Owen
five and picked TCU getting 13 points
here's he's listening to me for because
you're talking about one of them in my
opinion one of the most talented running
backs I've seen since LaDainian
Tomlinson dare I say
and he's in his first playoff game but
Daniel Thomason that might have been the
most exciting moment at that TCU game
when he came out and talked before the
game started yeah he has a cowboy hat on
and he's next to his son that was the
[ __ ] it that was the highlight of tcu's
night that was brutal man so if TCU was
in the Premier League they lost so bad
they wouldn't be in the league they'd
get kicked out of the league
what were you gonna say Andrew the prop
line for uh for saquan rushing is uh 72
and a half so so nice over 70. I'll take
that until we go over 72 and and we'll
do sick one to get a touchdown and the
Giants getting getting three I like that
all right I gotta go Paul I got
something here I'm already 10 minutes
late for uh all right man well this has
been uh this has been it everybody this
has been um the uh first week of
playoffs we'll be here next week we'll
take you right through the Super Bowl
you think we care
um well if you beat the book again next
year you gotta come on with the wizard
turban with that fake Jewel on it
if I do it three times in a row bet MGM
needs to do something bad MGM needs to
give me something I want to go they call
him the wizard all right everybody they
would just said back to back to you
meaning you beat me twice they're not
gonna put it out there that you beat
their asses twice no no no I I said I
said beat the book twice I was talking
to Jerry okay all right look at that
look at that I'm being negative yeah it
wasn't about apologies to bet and MGM
all right that's it I gotta go Paul I'm
late we're out of here uh all right
everybody there you go uh download the
uh app and uh use use uh bonus code Burr
that's it we're out of here hope you
enjoy this week's playoffs uh and I was
happy to do it again take care and
remember guys to bet you got to be 21
years of age or older to wager in
Arizona Colorado DC Iowa Indiana Kansas
Michigan Mississippi New Jersey New York
Nevada Pennsylvania Tennessee
uh Virginia West Virginia or Wyoming
only new customer offer paid in free
bets visit betmgm.com for terms and
conditions uh excludes Michigan
disassociated persons uh please gamble
responsibly gambling problem call 1-800
next step for Arizona call
1-800-522-4700 for Colorado DC Nevada
Wyoming West Virginia
1-800-270-7117 for confidential help
Michigan
1-800 Gambler in Indiana New Jersey
Pennsylvania and West Virginia
1-800 bets off in Iowa call or text the
Tennessee Red Line
800-889-9789 in Tennessee or call
1-88-77-9696 from Mississippi sports
betting is void in Georgia Hawaii Ohio
and Utah and other states were
prohibited
promotional offers not available in
Nevada
[Applause]